Hello, hello, hello, everybody.
Hello, guys.
Today, we're gonna finally finish Halo.
Finally.
No bait this time, no bait.
Because I feel a lot more refreshed and I can actually do a long, enjoying stream today.
If, um, um, if, uh, oh, wait, it's not the thumbnail.
Oh, wait, whoops, wrong outfit.
Okay, do you want me to be in the swimsuit or the school outfit?
Guys, I'll let you guys pick.
Because we're gonna be seeing me for a while.
How about, like, halfway through, we'll swap, okay?
Halfway through, I'll just go back into my closet and change clothes.
Like...
Because it's gonna be, I don't know how, how many hours we have left.
It really depends on, like, um, how long I can stay alive.
Um, how many times I can get fucked up by, uh, the flood.
Uh, so, I don't know.
Maybe halfway through.
We'll, we'll swap outfits halfway through, guys.
How about that?
Um, um, but yes, today we're gonna be trying, we're gonna finish Halo.
Um, I have no idea.
Um, how many hours I technically have left in this game.
Um, but, for those who are wondering, if I'm gonna go straight to Halo 2 right after, um, I am, I'm gonna, like, take a little buffer in between to do a new game series.
Um, to, like, you know, I like to do a buffer in between so we don't do, like, back-to-back-to-back when it comes to, like, uh, series.
Uh, so, I'm not sure what game I'm gonna try next week.
Okay, let me see.
There is a game I really wanna try, but I'm gonna double-check.
Uh, how long, how long to beat this game?
Uh, let me double-check.
Okay, I might start Epic Mickey next week because Epic Mickey is a game I've always wanted to play for the longest time.
So, we're going from Halo, uh, the, haha, the most bro, uh, game, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha,
haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha,
haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha, haha I am not a Disney adult.
I am not a Disney adult because I have never been... I've never like... I don't know.
I don't see myself as a Disney adult because I'm really obsessed.
Okay, how I categorize Disney adults are those that actually spend an exuberant amount of money to visit Disney World slash Disneyland every single day.
Oh, to be fair, the only thing that's preventing me is because I live in Canada.
Like, there's no Disneyland in Canada.
I don't know why.
But, but, because, not because I'm Canadian that I don't do that.
But one of the things I see Disney adults love to do is pin collecting.
And like, I don't know.
I'm not a... I don't know.
I don't understand the minds of like the pin collectors where they would like actually...
There's like, like, there's whole fucking society when it comes to like pin collecting.
And, um, yeah, those are on another level.
Um, and they would like, every day they'll go to these boards to like trade pins.
And then like staff members have like trivias, trivia questions that they give the pin collectors where they can trade for like secret trivia pins.
And then, currently, they're doing a thing for the Disney...
What is it?
50th anniversary...
Is it 50th anniversary or 100th?
I don't remember.
Uh, like the new anniversary thing at Disneyland where they're doing a thing about the key thing.
Like where, uh, they have...
Yeah, it's a cult.
No, I 100% agree.
Like, um, 100th anniversary where they get a key and they have to visit every land in Disneyland or like every like sector in Disneyland to like, like, um, to like unlock their key, like a key blade.
And then each key has a unique pin you have to collect out of like eight pins.
And then the key itself costs like 50 plus dollars.
So it's like, what, you just buy 50...
Like, you want to buy eight keys and test your luck?
Like...
Because if you're collecting...
If you're collecting all those pins, the only way to get it is to like have the key.
Or like, I guess you could like buy it off, trade it with other collectors.
But I feel like the other collectors would also want to complete their collection.
So the only way to actually complete your collection is to buy like eight more keys.
And then that's like what?
You have to buy eight more keys that are like 50 plus dollars each, not including tax.
And then I guess like trade your remaining pins to like get the full set.
Like, that's crazy.
Oh my god.
Um, that's so much work.
There's a channel that some...
There's a channel that sometimes pops up on my YouTube algorithm for shorts.
Where all they do every day...
They're like a married...
They're like a married couple.
And their entire channel is dedicated to like trading pins every day.
And like their whole goal is like...
Today we're gonna find...
Um...
We're gonna make...
It's a competition between husband and wife.
So like today we're gonna see who can collect the most pins based off of like Disney shoes or something like that.
Or like we're gonna see who has the pin that has the most numbers on their pin.
And it's like every day is a fucking challenge.
And they do this like...
They upload these shorts every fucking day.
So they must go to Disneyland almost every...
Because I...
I don't know.
They...
They have different clothes every time.
Like so I don't know if they like change their clothes in between.
So that like...
In between these shorts.
So it makes it seem like they're there on different days.
Or like they film it in bulk.
Because I don't understand like every...
Because I'm like...
Do they just like...
Do they go to Disneyland every day?
Like...
To do this challenge.
And like...
Whoever...
Whoever wins...
Um...
Gets to pick the lunch for today.
And I'm just like...
Do you just...
Go to Disneyland every day?
To...
To collect pins?
I'm like...
Holy fuck.
I was like...
Yeah.
Jesus.
Okay.
But like...
The shorts kept popping up.
And it...
I don't know.
It's so addicting.
Because it's like...
It's like...
Who's gonna win this time?
But...
Who's gonna win this...
Pin collection challenge this time?
And it's so addicting to watch.
I couldn't...
Because like...
You know...
I just live by cutesy through them.
I...
I've obviously won't do that.
But it's like...
Damn.
That's what life is like over there.
For...
You're...
Yeah.
I'm endabling it.
Like...
Yeah.
I'm encouraging it.
Like...
Because like...
You know...
I wouldn't do it.
But I don't mind seeing them do it.
Like...
It's like...
You know...
You're like...
Um...
You know...
You're at a zoo.
And you know...
You're...
You buy a ticket to the zoo.
So that...
You know...
But the ticket sales on that will help the zoo, like, make sure the animals can continue to live their lives.
That's me.
I'm buying a ticket right now to see these Disney adults continue to live their lives so I can be entertained.
So they can continue to do their thing.
I'll be like, oh, that's interesting.
We have to protect their habitat.
Exactly.
We have to protect their lifestyle, guys.
How else will I be entertained, chat?
This is so dystopian.
What the fuck, Doki?
How else would I be entertained, chat?
Like, I'm not gonna do it, but I'm okay with watching someone else do it.
But yeah, most likely next week we're gonna do...
We're gonna do an Epic Mickey because it seems like it's like...
Okay, it says, like, it takes, like, 13 hours to do.
Also, by the way, um, thank you everyone for replying to, like, what are some of the games you've grown up with?
Because I'm actually using that to figure out what to play, like, like, games to play in the future.
Because, like I said, I didn't grow up with a lot of, um, uh, typically normal childhood games.
Because I just played my dad's hand-me-downs.
Um, so there's a lot of games that I didn't really, like, have a chance to play.
So that's why I was, like, using that as, like, and then it went, it went viral.
I didn't, I didn't expect the tweet to get, like, how many, it got, like, um, it got out of, like, my general audience.
Uh, because I got, like, 3 point, not viral, but, like, it got, like, 3.4k replies.
I mean, yay.
I'll boost my own Twitter algorithm unintentionally.
I, I, yeah, it left my circle because I had, like, random people replying.
Um, so, like, I got a lot of suggestions, though.
So, that's good.
So, I can, you know, use that for future when I, like, figure out what games to play next.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Yay, engagement bait.
Unintentional engagement bait.
It's, like, those people that make tweets, like, um, name, I bet you can't.
Name a VTuber whose name doesn't have, like, E in it.
And then I, like, you know, I ego search myself and do, like, uh, Doki, oh, wait.
Doki Bird.
It's, like, that's easy, dude.
And I would see that.
But, like, that is clear, like, engagement baiting.
Like, oh, I think the amount of times I see, like, people making, like, those fucking tweets.
It's being, like, um, I bet you can't name a VTuber, uh, whose, uh, name, like, name doesn't have A in it.
Like, shit, like, it's so blatant, too.
Um, um, uh, someone has played both of the following games.
You're not necessarily a Disney adult.
You play Epic Mickey.
You're absolutely a Disney adult.
And you can't shut up about Kingdom Hearts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, this is just like when I super in order to let Doki continue her DoorDash lifestyle.
It's, like, oh, my God.
That reminds me, like, the Uma Musume tweet that I saw.
Where, like, you know, you can, like, donate, like, you can donate $5 to send Haru, like, what's her name?
Haru?
Some grass.
And basically, sending me a super chat provides me food.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It's, like, you know, it's just like that.
Uh, if you super chat me, I can, I can also get DoorDash.
Uh, Mr. BrokenPod, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Got it.
You just like to watch others do something fun together.
Freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Super to support my psychotic people watching like Doki does.
Except for me, it's me, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can you believe people waste money on Disney twins?
Giving money to YouTubers hoping they'll notice your Supa and say your name is a better use of money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
With our support, Doki will not go hungry.
Alright, I was debating if I should get... if I should uber slash skip the dish food tonight.
Because I was like, I've been cooking the last two days.
So, I can be lazy today.
Because my visitors today, sent me my droite My visitors today made sure that I could eat tonight And same name!
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you, thank you.
5$ to enable Doki's unhealthy habits.
Sign me up.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Supra, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
Same hay, some hay for Toki.
Is this how it works?
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, yeah.
And, like, I've been, like, thinking about, like, because I've been wanting to eat more, like, healthier lately.
Because, like, you know, I haven't been eating healthy the last month and a half because I've been so fucking stressed out.
So, you know, I've been, like, you know, I've been, like, I just want comfort food after, like, long days of work and stuff.
So I haven't been eating healthy the last month and a half because I've just been, like, you know, mostly ordering food.
I don't want to go outside.
Recently, I've been looking at pre-cooked meals.
You know those places that deliver food to you, but they're pre-cooked meals by chefs that are meant to have different meal plans, basically.
It's not like you're ordering from a restaurant, but they're more healthier because it's like
they're more so like they have a calorie.
Oh, this is if you're looking for this to this amount of calories.
And then they give you the menu and everything of what they're cooking.
And then if they deliver you on the day, they make it, too.
So I was looking into that because I saw a few of my friends have been ordering them, too.
And they said like, oh, it's like pretty good and it's actually pretty healthy.
And I saw one of the menus where I'm ordering the one in my city.
So it's not like they're not like actual like... No, it's not HelloFresh.
HelloFresh, you have to cook it yourself.
So I don't want to cook it myself right now because I just want to because I know like next month I might be like super busy.
So I'm ordering one where I'm ordering from a place where it's from my city.
And they're gonna... They're gonna like send me like... It's gonna start next week.
Uh...
They're gonna start... It's gonna start next week.
I'm gonna try it out.
I'm gonna see how I feel about it.
And I saw the menu.
It looks really, really good.
I wish I could show you the pictures, but I can't because it's literally just for my city.
So it's just for my city.
So I was like... So if I show you the pictures, it's more doxable.
London is my city.
Um...
And...
And anyway, so...
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Fuck.
There's something else I was gonna say.
Oh, someone's like... Isn't it expensive?
I actually calculated it.
It's cheaper than ordering on... on like...
Like Uber or like DoorDash or... or Skip the Dishes.
It's cheaper.
Because the meals are healthier.
And, um...
And they're like...
Um...
And...
They cost less.
And shipping is free.
Because I ordered like...
A week and a half of worth of...
A week and a half...
Actually, no.
Is it a week?
Or...
I think it is.
A week's worth of...
Uh...
The meals to test it out.
Because you can only order like a week...
Um...
Minimum.
So I'm ordering like a week minimum just to test it out.
Uh...
But it is cheaper than me ordering out...
From...
Um...
From like Uber Eats and stuff all the time.
And then...
There were two...
There was another one that I almost ordered.
Because I was like...
Oh, this seems healthy.
And I looked at the...
FAQ.
And they're like...
Typically...
We serve senior citizens.
But...
We also...
Um...
We're also very...
We try...
We try to up a variety and...
Uh...
And...
And like...
It's not...
It's not just usually...
We can also serve people from all ages.
And I was like...
Okay.
I shouldn't get that one.
I...
At first...
I was sent to order this one.
Because it was closer to me too.
It was closer to me.
And they're like...
Well, typically...
We try to make these meals for senior citizens.
Who might need it.
Because...
Um...
They can't really move around as much anymore.
I was like...
Oh...
The food looks so good.
I was looking at the picture.
I was like...
Oh...
This looks really good.
Let me look at the...
I almost earned it.
Because...
But then I read the FBQ.
And I was like...
Oh...
Man...
Maybe not.
I was just like...
Oh...
This is awkward.
Maybe...
Like...
I know I just had my birthday.
But like...
I still got some...
I still got some life in me.
But I went with a different one.
That was also...
Was not geared towards senior citizens.
Um...
I still have some gas left in this tank.
Yeah.
I haven't...
I haven't been like...
Lightning McQueen in...
What was it?
In the third movie.
Oh god.
That fucking...
I remember that...
That...
When the trailer...
For Cars...
Was it Cars 3?
Came out with a poster.
That shit went hard.
Everyone was like...
Holy fuck.
Was it Cars 3?
Where it looked like he was gonna fucking die?
Like...
It did.
Bro...
Guys...
I'm not...
I'm still...
I'm still Cars 1.
Lightning McQueen.
Guys...
Ka-chow.
I...
Yeah...
Like...
He was gonna fucking die...
In the trailer.
Like...
The poster went so fucking hard...
For no reason too.
I was like...
Holy shit.
Like...
Yeah...
Okay...
This is actually...
This is...
Okay...
For those who've never seen...
The Cars 3 poster...
That like...
Um...
That...
That first came out...
To tease...
Cars 3...
Here it is...
That shit looked...
It was like...
Holy shit...
Do they kill off Lightning McQueen?
Like...
This is literally...
The...
Teaser drop...
For...
Cars 3...
Like...
That was the first teaser drop for it.
It goes so fucking hard.
Everyone thought like...
They were gonna kill off Lightning McQueen.
Like...
He's...
Yeah...
And then like...
Um...
And then the...
And then the first teaser trailer...
For the movie...
The movie as well...
Was also fucking insane.
Like...
Yeah...
The trailer started with him fucking crashing his car.
It was like...
Jesus...
He's...
Dead.
Imagine you're a kid...
And you saw this...
And you're like...
Lightning McQueen?
He...
Ka-chow...
He cursed his last chow.
Oh...
That's not...
I'm not Cars 3...
McQueen yet.
Guys...
I best carve Cars 2!
I'm...
Uh,
thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you saw some of my lists...
Before I got down...
Drowned out by everybody else.
If you were to play some N64 games from my childhood, it would make my day.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One more to go.
Powerpuff, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's some grass for you.
Om nom nom.
Thank you for feeding me, chat.
Meep, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Meep.
Alright, I'll make sure to do a super chat reading at the end of the stream, guys.
Because we gotta start this game because it's gonna be a long stream.
Ayako, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That trailer for Cars 3 was so cinematic and dark, I still couldn't believe that was the same studio who made the previous one, and the same studio that made planes, guys.
Remember when they tried to be like, let's create a cinematic universe within Cars, and then they made fucking planes?
And... They tried to make a fucking cinematic universe.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Planes was actually from Disney, not from Pixar.
And yeah, do you know who owns Pixar?
You guys know?
Guys, that's like seeing, like, guys, like, you guys are like, yeah, Pixar and Disney, two very different studios.
I'm pretty sure Pixar staff had it's had working on planes as well, guys.
I'm pretty sure.
It's not the same team.
Oh, sure.
Sure, it's not.
Anyway, let's boot up.
Let's boot up.
Halo.
Halo time.
Alright.
Halo.
Halo Missionary Zero will be at that day.
I'm gonna make sure every week there's a collab.
But I didn't want to do too many collabs.
Because I need to conserve my...
Collabs take a lot of my energy.
So I'm trying to conserve my energy when it comes to group settings.
So I'm making sure it's just one collab per week.
But yeah, I'm gonna do...
Next Friday, it's gonna be Peak with Mint, Snuffy, and Laimu.
And then the Friday after that is part two of the Zero.
The fucking fucked up game where we get like spawn camp.
So that's gonna be on the 25th.
Alright.
Wait, that's not...
We're not multiplayer.
I was like, wait a minute.
This doesn't look right.
Alright.
Black screen.
No, it's still here.
Slop Peak Sisters.
That crap.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Alright.
Okay.
Here I go.
Here?
Where I go?
Hello?
Is that not where I go?
Pretty sure.
Yeah, that's the door.
Oh, wait.
The panel.
Forgot.
Okay.
1 HP and...
I might have like saved at the worst possible place.
And I remember you guys too were like, hey, uh, you should really, uh, you should...
Oh shit, thank god.
Wait, aren't they bad people now?
Oh shit, forgot they're bad people now too.
Oh.
I was like, oh, thank god my heroes.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait, they're all so bad.
I'm...
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is actually very bad for me.
Oh shit.
This is very bad.
I literally am one hit.
Okay, this is not good.
Alright.
This is fine.
Does that go over here?
There you go.
Alright.
Did that hit him?
Okay.
Please tell me there...
Please tell me there's heals somewhere close by.
Please tell me there is heals somewhere.
Oh my god.
I just need heals like anywhere.
Okay, I like this gun more.
There you go.
Alright.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
I have 35 bullets.
There's no heals yet.
There's no heals.
No heals.
Alright.
Oh.
Hello?
Hello everybody?
Am I...
I'm not safe.
I don't feel very safe right now.
Hello?
Oh, I don't...
Okay, it's good.
There's a checkpoint.
Oh my god.
That's my own shield.
Framed me.
Oh my god.
I do not feel safe.
That's fine.
We recharge.
Slow and steady.
Hello?
I know you're alive.
Like...
I...
It's big like...
Oh, it...
Like, I'll...
She'll forget.
Don't worry.
There we go.
I was like, what are you doing?
Like, I know you're still there.
Like, where the fuck?
Why are you hiding?
I haven't completed the crash site yet, but we need to buy some time.
He's also, he's like, she'll forget.
She'll forget.
Maybe, yeah, up the tower.
Oh, please tell me where the fuck is the helos.
Where is it?
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
I'm marking the location of the nearest pulse generator with a nav point.
We need to move in and neutralize the device.
Okay.
Wait, do I...
I don't know.
Do I keep the shotgun or do I get...
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, wait.
No, I should get that.
Okay.
This is good.
Sniper...
Sniper pistol.
This is good.
God damn it, it's bulletproof.
God damn stupid bulletproof glass.
Keep the shotgun.
Oh, but like...
Guys...
But like, look.
I have a pistol.
I'll need...
Oh, it's too late.
I don't want to go back.
It's too late.
Oh, shit!
Wait, what hit me?
It's too late.
We've already made our choice.
What?
Okay, that's it.
Oh, it's four shots.
Okay.
Memento.
Thank you for the super shot.
Thank you, thank you.
Get ready to enjoy the backtrack portion of the game.
Thankfully, Halo 2 won't do this, but still has a library.
All right, guys.
I made my choice.
Oh my god, that's it.
Okay, I can't see your...
I can't see your face.
Let me press tap real quick.
Okay, we gotta go down.
Sorry, guys.
I had to...
I had to do it.
I couldn't see.
Hey, where do I go?
Oh, down here.
There we go.
We don't need a flashlight!
Actually...
Oh my god!
Okay, I hate that.
I hate when it...
Oh my god, and he gets like a free shot off of me because of it.
I hate when, like, they shoot me and I unscope.
That's my pet peeve.
Gotta make sure.
Oh my god, my sniper ammo.
I don't have a lot, please.
Okay, nice.
All right, I'm gonna throw that there.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna...
You're gonna do that?
Because I'm lazy?
All right.
Goddammit!
Wait.
I swear to god.
Ah!
Okay, I'll stop fucking around.
Okay.
Nevermind.
I thought it'd look cool.
I thought it would look cool!
Okay?
I legitimately thought it would look really cool if I hit it.
It was all about the risk.
Okay, fuck this.
There we go.
Oh, shit!
Fuck's up to me!
Like...
That's all I...
Okay, guys.
Maybe I should have got the shotgun, guys.
Guys, I might have made a mistake.
Oh, wait.
I'd live these, right?
Oh, shit, nice.
Okay.
I live these.
Aha!
Told you.
I live these.
Oh my god, these guys are such bitches.
Are you serious?!
What hit me?!
I live these.
You're kidding me?!
That hit me, guys.
Gold!
He's gold!
Oh my god, he's gold!
Okay.
We got rid of him.
Okay, bye.
I feel safe.
I feel so safe down here.
Or up here.
What the fuck is shooting me?
Oh, it's up there.
Okay, that's nothing to worry about.
Okay, it's fine.
We're okay.
We still have bullets.
Okay, that should have been a headshot.
Come on!
That was such an easy headshot.
Oh, no.
Do I have enough?
Okay, I do have enough.
Okay, I was a little worried that I might not have enough for the fucking tank that may or may not be on the other side.
Is that the tank?
Okay, I hope that was the tank.
Because I want to grab that banshee.
Oh my god, that was the tank.
No!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
Okay, I don't want to get back up.
I don't know why I get back up.
Okay.
It's fine.
That shouldn't hit me.
Fucking whore.
Oh my god, he's using the banshee as a body block.
He knows I need that.
Okay, nice.
Okay, now I should be able to get on to that.
Right?
How do I fly?
Guys, how do I fly?
Guys!
Fly, how?
Oh my god, I'm flying.
Oh my god, I'm a beautiful bird.
Oh my god, I'm doing it.
Yay!
I can fly!
Okay, nice.
Can I bring it in?
Oh.
I mean, that was fun.
Let me in.
Wait, I want to be inside.
Are you serious?
Yes.
No!
They won't let me in.
They can't bring my banshee in.
There's like no flying allowed.
Professor Oak kneecapped me.
It's not a good time to fly.
Okay.
I'm gonna go this way.
Hello?
Oh.
Maybe there's just some secrets?
Some heals?
No heals?
Okay.
I did it.
Oh, it's that easy.
Objective accomplished.
Yay!
Oh shit!
Oh no, I don't have...
Oh no!
Oh, I'm so fucked up.
I'm so fucked up right now.
Oh, the tech support is here.
Better get up.
Oh no, I don't have plasma weapons.
Oh!
Okay, I have this.
That's fucking...
What the fuck?
He lives?
Okay.
Yeah, I know I can just leave, but they're all surrounding the exit.
This is as fast as I can go, guys.
Oh my god.
It's poking me.
My little pokes.
Okay, we gotta swap guns.
Hello?
Okay.
Where is it?
Mark the target with the nav point when we get closer.
Yeah, I need that.
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
Hello.
Flying over now.
Is he dead?
The
second pulse dinner is located in the adjacent canyon.
Alright.
Well, now we know.
Now.
No.
He was, in fact, not dead.
He was...
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know he can just kill me like that?
Like, who killed me?
Who was it?
Oh my god, it was you.
I see your shots.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
The second pulse generator is located in the adjacent canyon.
Move out and I'll mark the target with the nav point when we get closer.
Oh my...
How does he just kill me like that?
How is he that good?
Okay, I'm getting out.
I'm getting out.
I don't trust.
I don't trust anyone.
I'm...
The world's strongest.
I'm getting out.
I'm getting out of here.
I'm not letting that happen again.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We're okay this time.
We're...
We're okay.
Fooled me at once, shame on you.
Head through that door.
That's the way to the next canyon.
Oh, I don't have enough pistol ammo anymore.
Oh, I hear something over here.
Alright.
Anybody on my right?
Just gotta be sure.
I just want to be sure there's nothing on my left side.
Actually.
What
the fuck?
He take three headshots!
Okay.
Get out of here.
Hello, little guys?
Little guys!
What am I doing?
Why am I wasting my stupid ammo on these guys?
I forgot about melee.
Alright.
Just gonna do that.
Just in case.
Okay, so what's the lore between like...
Why do like...
The little guys know English?
And then these guys are just like...
Rawr!
How come he knows English?
What's the lore?
I thought they were like, lower level.
Compared to the others.
Little guys are just like...
Warp, warp, warp.
Because they're...
Okay, but why are the grunts more educated?
Unless the...
Um...
They translate...
Oh, only the grunt language is translated.
Oh!
Alright.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Are elites like...
Extra racist?
So they don't bother learning English?
Because it's beneath them?
And then in the grunt lore...
Like grunts are like...
English to them is like...
You know...
Um...
Like at their level?
Like...
Like I was gonna say...
Like cause they're grunts...
They're like...
Oh yeah, speak their language.
Cause you're just their level.
Like is that it?
That would make sense.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Are they...
They're just like...
Bro...
Like I'm not your level.
Oh no.
Oh, the needler gun got me.
Oh, that's bad.
It's okay.
We're five.
I had...
I took too many needles.
Too much acupuncture.
It's not good.
We're just gonna wait.
They're real time.
Google translator.
Oh, and then so like...
The elites don't bother.
Because they're too good.
They're too good for us.
Uh...
Neppers!
Thank you again for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
Oh, does that not hit you?
It's like...
You'll come to me.
Oh shit.
Nevermind.
Let me hear.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep.
There you go.
Oh, I thought he was gonna go right.
I mean, that's smart.
Alright.
This was the longest, like...
Chicken that we played.
What word word?
The fuck no, it's cold.
Oh my god!
Wait, is that the fly?!
Okay.
Did not expect him to come back.
I did not expect him to come back.
I...
I felt so safe, but...
What the fuck are they doing?!
Why didn't they deal with the blind?!
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, I wish I had my shotgun.
I wish I had my shotgun right now.
Don't be good.
The shotgun.
That's right, peek me.
Oh my god, they're crouching that fucker.
They don't.
Come on, I know your head level.
Wait, what?
Who's coming in?
Okay, you guys get out of here.
You're not part of this fight.
Guys, you're not part of this fight!
Leave!
Leave this fight!
This is between me and the elites!
Oh my god!
You're not part of this!
Get out of here!
I'm trying to...
Oh my god.
Okay, we got one of them.
Okay.
There we go.
Now you can join in!
Oh my god, there we go.
Alright.
What the fucking shit?
That scared me.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh my god, that's fine.
Bro, fuck this.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
You think you're part of...
Bro, this guy thinks he's part of the team.
Benza, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Old lore was that the grunts are super intelligent and will learn other language speech patterns because they were used to intercept human comms and crack it for the elites.
Oh!
I see.
Okay, that makes sense.
That's gonna say, why are they speaking English to me?
Like...
I figured, like, you know, they have better...
Like, I was like, why...
Why are they speaking English?
Like, they're very accommodating, you know?
You know, they don't have...
Like, it's literally just me.
But...
They're still willing to speak English.
Oh!
Okay, maybe they'll fight each other.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, that's good.
So accommodating, you know?
That's so nice of them.
It's literally...
Oh my god.
My lights flickered just then.
I...
I was like, why did my lights flicker?
That was so scary.
That was actually so scary.
I don't know why my lights flickered.
It's like a ghost.
A ghost came in to haunt me.
Yeah, I can use that.
Alright.
Yeah, I don't know if you guys noticed.
I just looked up.
Alright.
Here I go.
Hello?
I'm outside now.
Oh shit.
That's a lot of shield damage.
Oh my god.
I don't know who they're shooting.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I was like, where did these guys come from?
Okay, I'm gonna...
Actually, they're like, so far away from me.
So I don't have to worry.
Like, they're shooting them.
So that's good.
I just have to shoot them.
Like, they're shooting them anyway.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I made it.
What?
What was that?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I was like, bro, what?
I thought you were distracted.
But they did kill the...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they came over.
Oh my god, they can jump.
Okay, nice.
I didn't think they would just jump over.
What the fuck?
They pretended to be dead!
He's like...
He's like, wait, why did you get in the way of my 1v1?
Bro, this was a 1v1, bro!
Bro, expect the 1v1!
That's right, I'm here, third party.
Alright, I think he's dead.
Wait, what?
I just wanna get rid of this guy first.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
No third party.
Alright, we can go forward now.
Nice.
Hello.
Here's something on the other side.
Wow, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hello, guys.
Anyone here?
Hello?
Anyone?
Oh, I see you.
I see you, Flood.
Oh, I see all of you.
Wow!
I see so many of you!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh my god, it's okay.
I acknowledge you.
It's alright.
You've been acknowledged!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Hello, everyone.
Again.
Hello.
Is everyone actually dead?
Are you all dead dead?
Okay.
As long as they're all actually dead dead, it's fine.
Oh my god, not these guys.
Okay.
I wanna make pop these fucking bubbles real fast.
There we go.
It's like a little pop... party popper.
Okay.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
Oh my god.
Little... party poppers.
Is there anything up here?
Gotta be sure.
If there's any loot up here.
I hear them.
They're like... they come up?
To fucking try and kill me?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
It's like I heard them.
Like, going...
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Okay, I got...
Alright, one of you is not actually dead.
I fucking knew it.
I...
I knew one of you guys were not...
Oh, hey!
Hey there, John!
I can tell...
I can tell who's pretending to be a...
Pretending to be dead.
I knew you were pretending!
Alright.
He just stood there.
Oh my god, he has his airpods!
Ah!
Oh my god, not again.
Not again.
Not again!
Guys, I had my airpods on.
I...
I had my airpods on chat.
Okay.
I gotta make sure I always have to...
Have like...
Gotta swap the gun for the alien...
The plasma guns.
So I can always have ammo for it.
I fucking knew you were...
Pretending.
Uh...
I can like literally just melee them.
They don't do enough.
Boop!
They're like little ants.
Alright.
Alright, you deserve that.
You get special treatment.
Boop!
Yeah, I hear them.
Oh, I hear them.
They're little popcorn!
Yeah!
Oh?
They sound like...
Like the...
The zerg sometimes.
Doesn't it?
Oh!
That's a rocket launcher.
But don't they sometimes sound like...
Zerg monsters?
Like...
Like when I...
When I click on the structures, you know?
Oh my god.
Why?
They're all...
They're all trying to get...
That's right.
Bulletproof blast, baby!
Can't get me!
Oh my god.
They all wanna fucking kill me.
Oh, I hear it.
I'm pretty sure the zergs came first.
Kill this guy real fast.
Okay, I killed the majority of their...
Their kind.
Alright, so I have to go that way.
But I wanna make sure there's nothing.
Ba-bop.
Are they still...
Oh my god.
They're still there.
Bro, get out.
Are you guys still there?
Get out!
Oh my god, it was...
It was not bulletproof.
Oh, thank god I didn't shoot it.
I...
It was not bulletproof.
I couldn't...
I almost shot it.
I was so tempted.
I almost shot at it.
Oh my god.
It was not bulletproof.
Thank god I didn't test my theory.
It would've been funny though.
It would've been funny.
I would've been funny.
Alright.
Like...
It would've been absolute karma.
If I did try and shoot it.
Okay.
I'm just gonna get rid of the...
Little...
The flood guys.
Instead.
Are you s- I'm helping you!
I'm fucking helping you!
Oh my god.
And you shoot me?!
I'm fucking helping you!
Oh my god.
He hates you specifically.
Bro, I'm just hoping they would shoot them!
Bro, I'm so mad.
I'm so mad.
You are a bigger fucker.
Cause it's so hard to shoot them.
The gun I have right now.
They hate you more.
They're like, fuck you in particular.
Oh, I thought I could...
Oh shit.
I thought the glass was breakable.
Just in case.
I knew it!
I fucking...
I fucking knew it was pretending to be dead too!
I am...
It's like, wait...
I was like, he's like, wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Fucking...
Kill him!
God damn it!
Are you serious?
He actually got...
Oh, I'm shooting them down.
Fuck this.
I'm shooting them down.
I gave you too much.
I already gave you too much of a chance to live.
That's right.
You don't deserve anymore.
There you go.
Get out of here.
I'll fight them myself.
I don't need you.
I don't fucking need you.
You know what?
You could have lived.
I would have let them live.
I would have.
I was going to.
But no.
No, he's gotta be a little bitch about it.
We needed this though.
I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
What is that?
Alright.
That's right.
Back shots.
Alright.
Okay.
These guys.
I'm not wasting any ammo on them.
Get out of here.
Popcorn!
There we go.
Oh shit.
That's a lot of them.
Uh.
Boop.
Pop.
Get out of here.
Your life doesn't matter.
What are you gonna do?
I have armor on.
You can't get inside me.
I have armor.
Fucking right.
Man.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
That's right.
Our protection.
You think about it.
My armor is gonna protect me.
And save me from God.
Save me for God.
There you go.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
What's that sound?
Oh shit!
Alright.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The non-bullet-proof glass.
Gotta make sure those pop.
There wasn't a lot.
As before.
Actually, I'm just gonna throw these names.
What the fuck?
I thought you were all dead.
You guys missed!
Oh fuck!
I got distracted!
Why are they all like, just standing there like a gang?
Okay.
Guys.
Chill!
I'll get to you later!
Oh!
Okay.
I was gonna say like, what the fuck was that sound?
It's okay.
I have a window.
I have a window!
That was a lot of them.
That's fine.
You should all be dead.
Alright.
This way.
You don't need armor.
It's okay.
The popcorn just wants to hold your hand.
Thank you for the super chat.
Ginger.
Thank you.
Alright.
Up I go.
Oh.
Down I go.
Nevermind.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
This is my elevator.
Alright.
This.
You think I...
Oh, you thought you could...
What the fuck?
Still here?
Bro.
Oh my god!
When does it stop?
Alright.
That's fine.
That should be all of them.
Hmm.
Bro, it's like rain.
Oh, they're dancing.
Just in case.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I knew you were a fuck.
Just in case.
Oh, I hear them right beside me.
There's a bunch of popcorn to my right.
I hear them.
They're ready to pop.
Wait.
No?
I didn't hear them?
Oh, I guess I didn't.
Guess I'm crazy.
Hello?
Oh?
Oh, I don't like this area.
Kill him in particular.
With that one guy though.
I just want...
I don't want to be...
waste my...
shotgun yet.
If I can.
I hear them.
I hear a lot of them somewhere.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't feel comfortable being in like, such an open area.
I hear like...
I hear them like, just calling for me.
Like Doki.
Doki.
Come on.
Eat the apple.
Oh, there you are.
There you go.
Come on.
All your friends are doing it.
Is it?
Did I come from here?
No, I didn't.
Okay.
Let's take care of the next pulse generator.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna...
Alright.
Nevermind.
I'll just...
I'll just stay here.
Stay here.
I'm just...
That's fine.
Okay.
Let me die.
Let me...
No.
Get me...
No, no.
Get me out of here.
No, no, no.
Get me...
Oh, now you can't aim at me.
Okay.
I have to walk.
Oh, now he misses.
I see.
I...
I was like, wow.
He hits the fucking shot of his life.
And now he missed every other shot after that.
No, I get it.
I...
I fucking get it.
Fuck me, right?
Like, how do I...
What?
I'm gonna wait a little bit.
I don't have a...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
Get to a safe part first.
Before I...
Let me just have a little fucking car fight.
OH MY GOD!
Guess I won't do that.
I guess I won't.
Fuck this.
Okay, nice.
There's healers here.
Okay, there's better be a fucking rocket launcher.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
There better be a goddamn rocket launcher.
Over here.
Alright, where is he?
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
Alright.
Where's that stupid tank?
Where is it?
No!
Oh my god.
This fucking sucks.
I'm gonna get rid of this too.
And then I'll get rid of him.
Oh my god.
Please.
I need to get rid of him.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
We're alive.
Get rid of that.
Get rid of him first.
We're alive.
You know what?
Fuck this guy too, in particular.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
It will blow you up.
Get out of here.
It was worth it.
How do I...
How do I fucking leave?
Okay.
One more shot.
No, I... I shouldn't.
What?
Oh shit.
No, that's not why I want it.
How do I...
How do I get up there?
Alright.
What?
Guys, I know you can't rocket jump.
I...
Get...
Fuck with me.
Don't fuck with me right now.
I just go forward?
Guys, we tried this before.
Press...
Just press jump really hard.
It'll work.
I guess I go down.
And you guys, they patched it.
Jerky, by the time you got there, they patched it.
Don't worry.
Oh, I guess I go down.
Yeah, they patched it just for me.
Wait, guys.
What about this?
Hey, guys.
Is this a secret tunnel?
I thought the rocket jumped, guys.
Why do I...
Why am I here, huh?
Why am I...
I thought you said the rocket jumped.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
He charged that up just for me.
It's the alternative path.
You won't understand.
What does...
I will break your shield.
Oh shit.
You'll break my shield first, apparently.
Fucker.
That's right.
I'm patient.
Alright.
Oh nice.
Someone died here.
I'll grab this.
And then...
Health.
And then I get my car.
Alright.
I don't know if it's good to be on the car though.
Actually.
Get over here.
There we go.
I'm like thinking.
Like...
Oh wait.
Like what do I do with my car?
Yeah.
I was gonna say.
Who's getting my...
I guess I could just run over people.
Get over here.
You fucker.
Oh thank god.
It passes through the car.
I was gonna say.
I will die with you.
I am...
I was ready to die with him.
Alright.
I can use it as a cover, right?
Holy shit.
Wait.
Oh shit.
Okay.
That was pretty sick.
Using that as cover.
Let me
kill this first.
Oh my god.
It's these guys.
I forgot they existed.
Okay.
He has to turn his backs.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I am already going through so much.
Okay.
He has to turn his back.
No.
I'm so bad at this.
Worth it.
Alright.
Oh.
Not here.
Alright.
Do I go this way?
Oh my god.
I'm so lost.
I'm so fucking lost.
Oh there it is.
Guys.
Can I just...
Explode it with my...
Gun?
Wait.
Can I just...
Destroy it with a pistol?
Guys?
Or no?
No?
Alright.
I'll just leave.
Goodbye.
God!
They're like...
You can never leave.
Keep.
Oh my god.
He saw me.
Oh no.
Okay.
Alright.
We just go this way.
God dammit.
Wait.
I can just steal it?
I'm going in.
God.
Thank you for the super champ.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh my...
Guys.
I...
I'm starting to not believe guys.
I gotta do this again.
Okay.
Watch this though.
Oh my god.
They do this guy again too.
God dammit.
I have to kill him again too.
I hate them.
I hate them so much.
I have to do this all over again.
I...
Eh.
I'm so sad.
Cause it was so cool too.
Are you serious?
You're fucking double teaming?
That's fucking...
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
Oh my god.
I have to deal with these guys.
Here we go.
I don't know why he ran back.
He got scared for some reason.
Or maybe you have to run back too.
I don't know.
Here we go.
Stupid.
Alright.
Let's go.
I don't need the galling gun.
I have a pistol.
Okay.
Let's get the galling gun.
Alright.
There you go.
Come on.
Peak.
Okay.
Get your ass out of here.
There's no way that's gonna hit me, right?
No.
He misses.
He misses those.
Guys.
Guys!
Okay.
He does not miss those.
He does not.
He doesn't miss those.
He doesn't miss those apparently.
Oh my god.
It's so hard to see where it's gonna hit.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No.
What's hitting me?
As long as I fly.
Can't get me.
As long as...
Is that coming towards me?
Weeeeee.
I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
I don't know what killed me.
I don't know.
I killed my s- I can do that?!
That- What the fuck my- That can happen- Oh my god.
I can crash.
Oh my god.
Nobody told me I could just fucking crash.
I didn't know.
I didn't know that was a thing.
I used to- Okay, that's fine.
I'll take it.
I didn't know that was a thing.
I can't.
I can't deal with this.
Oh my god.
They're everywhere.
I'm so sad.
I was- I did this to myself.
No.
The second level.
The second level is like the death of me right now.
It is actually...
The worst.
Fucking hell, this is the worst level.
I'm fucking waiting for the Banshee to show up.
Show its goddamn face.
There you are.
I knew you'd show up.
Get out of here.
I knew you'd fucking show up and show your goddamn face.
Oh my god.
It's like this fucktoki.
In particular.
He actually...
He actually did it.
He actually fucking did it.
Oh my god.
The Mad Men.
The fucking Mad Men actually did it.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Get out!
Oh my god.
I thought he was gonna do it again.
I legitimately thought he was gonna do it.
Oh my- Oh I- Are you serious?
I used to- It hit me twice.
It hit me twice.
Oh my god.
It actually hit me.
Today's not a good day.
Today is not a good day for Doki.
Okay, we're just gonna kill this guy.
I-I'm missing everything.
I'm-I'm just not ha- I'm-I'm not okay anymore.
I'm- I'm not okay.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
I hit every shot before and now I hit nothing.
Now I can't anymore.
I-I'm not.
I'm-I'm a-I'm a shadow of a man right now.
I-I'm what I once was.
I-
I hate this tank.
I hate this tank so fucking much.
I-I-I don't know if it's gonna hit me or not.
Oh my god, it's getting closer isn't it.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
No it's five.
It's FIVE.
It's fine.
I'll stay here until it works.
Please.
Oh my god.
Every time it gets closer.
It feels like it's getting closer, guys.
It really does feel like it's getting closer.
I'm suppressing fire.
There we go.
Okay, we're fine.
I just have to kill this.
Okay.
We just... make sure we don't crash.
We gotta make sure we don't crash.
Alright, up we go.
Wee!
Just don't crash.
Just don't fucking crash.
Oh my god.
Get me.
Get me out of here.
Oh, we made it.
We fucking made it.
Oh my god.
We made it, everyone.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
We're okay.
There we go.
Of course.
A fucking course.
A fucking cortes.
Oh fucking course!
They're just all there.
They're just all there!
Ah!
I'm bugging it!
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
I am actually not okay.
I am not okay right now.
I... Holy shit.
One HP and a dream.
Okay.
Please tell me there's health packs.
Please tell me there's a health pack.
This is the hardest level.
Good luck chasing you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
We're okay.
Hello.
Tunnels below?
I... I swear to god.
Is that a plane?
Is that a god damn plane?
Let's take care of the final pullback.
Okay.
Good.
He killed himself.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
Where the fuck do I go?
Where do I go?
Flight... Oh wait.
Oh I remember.
Okay.
Oh okay.
This way over here.
Oh my god.
He can't...
He can't reach me.
He can reach me.
I can't make it.
I thought that guy... I thought that guy wouldn't kill me.
We'll need to find him, or his neural implants, to start the fusion core detonation.
One target remaining.
Let's take care of the final pulse generator.
So close to the ceiling.
Damn.
He can't see me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Open the door.
Open the door, open the door.
Open the door!
Oh my god, I have to open the door.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Go through these.
I'm crisp in the air.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I can't break- NOOO!
No!
He won't let me bring him through.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so fucked up.
Oh my god.
I thought I could bring the banshee over.
I had hope for like five seconds.
I thought I could just fly over.
Okay.
I'm serious.
I can't be bothered.
I had to.
I decided to use it.
Just to double tap.
I knew it.
I was like, you were so far away from that shot.
There was no way.
Alright.
I'm just kidding.
Oh my god, who's shooting me?
Oh!
Oh no.
Oh, they're shooting me.
They're shooting back now.
They know!
Okay.
Alright.
I needed new guns.
Oh, they shoot back.
Oh, thank god!
Oh my god!
They're evolving!
Okay.
Open sesame.
My only weakness bullets!
How did they know?
How did they know that was my only weakness?
They knew they were...
They knew.
Try to bring the banshee.
Falcor.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Combat evolved.
You don't remember?
Maybe it used to look like this for you.
This is what it used to look like.
Sorry, flashbang.
My eyes!
Wait.
Did I make it?
Is this the last chapter?
Oh my...
Guys!
I think I'm at the last chapter, guys!
The final run!
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Okay.
Nevermind.
I'm not at the last chapter.
I don't know.
It said final run.
I assumed that meant final chapter.
How did that miss all of them?
Just let it pop.
Of this level.
I think we can just fight each other.
I'm okay with that.
I swear to God.
I broke the...
I...
I located the pillar of autumn.
She put down twelve hundred kilometers up spin.
Energy readings show her fusion reactors are still powered up.
The systems on the pillar of autumn have fail-saves.
Even I can't override without authorization from the captain.
We'll need to find him or his neural implants to start the fusion core detonation.
There's no checkpoint?
One target remaining.
Let's take care of the final pulse generator.
There's...
What?
Where did my checkpoint go?
Where...
How is there no checkpoint?
Oh!
Oh my God!
And he's gonna...
Oh, my bad!
She's...
Oh my God!
I don't understand!
Wow there's gonna be a lot.
What did my checkpoint go!
It's God!
Aren't I supposed to have a checkpoint?!
It bugged out.
That actually happened to me.
The checkpoint actually bugged out.
Oh my god.
I was supposed to have a checkpoint and it actually bugged out.
That's... oh my god.
Oh my god.
How is that possible?
Oh my
god.
I can't believe.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Checkpoint done.
I can't.
Where is it?
It didn't show save.
It didn't not show checkpoints.
How is that possible?
How do I have zero checkpoints?
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
I don't even know.
I don't even know if I got the checkpoint here.
Oh my god.
I went through so much.
I actually did so much.
That's crazy that there was no checkpoint.
That's actually crazy.
That... I can't believe they did that to me.
I can't believe they did that.
Oh my god.
They actually did that to me.
After everything I've been through.
Oh.
Oh my god.
That guy was crazy.
That guy was actually crazy.
Holy shit.
He knew he was gonna be dead.
Oh, where's...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it took me all the way there.
I...
Come on.
Where's checkpoint?
Checkpoint.
What?
No name to you.
The super chat that you think.
Where's the checkpoint?
Where is it?
Was checkpoint done?
Please.
Where is it?
Oh no.
Checkpoint.
I'm here.
Checkpoint done.
Checkpoint save?
Checkpoint.
What's that?
That's it?
Okay.
Alright.
I believe.
I'm gonna go to the left side.
It seems safer.
I'll just let them fight a little bit.
I swear to god.
Okay.
You better fucking die.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Holy shit.
They all came after me.
Oh my god.
They just all wanted me dead.
Oh.
I can't go left.
I actually can't go left.
Let's see if I can get the guy on this.
Oh my god.
They all turned around.
They actually all turned around.
What is fucking wrong with these freaks?
Okay.
You have alerted the horde.
I actually did.
Oh my god.
They won.
The flood won.
Okay.
We gotta find...
A gun replacement for this.
Anywhere.
Anywhere, please.
Uh...
Oh, my God.
I want a needler.
Okay.
Not anywhere.
Oh my god.
Alright.
That's okay.
We have a car.
It's okay.
Anything but that.
Okay, I'm just gonna back up a little.
Oops.
Okay, maybe that's too much backed up.
Okay.
I'm just gonna shoot him.
Okay, let me have your gun.
I actually need your gun.
Okay, I'll wait.
Except for him.
I'll kill him.
Oh!
Oh, no.
This is not good.
I don't have enough ammo.
Oh, please.
Oh, wait, nice!
There's a gun here!
Oh, what gun is this?
Oh, not the gun I needed, but that's okay.
Okay, I'll take it.
I'll just take it.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, my God!
Oh!
Are you fucking kidding?
Oh, my God!
Are you serious?
I just... Okay, there's a health pack.
There's a health pack.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
It was a health pack.
He blew himself up, too.
And I got shotgun ammo.
Oh!
Everything will be okay.
Doki.
I got spare heals.
Can you make clutch?
Checkpoint that this better be fucking checkpoint that I swear to God.
I'm playing more careful now because I don't know.
I swear to God, if I die and I go all the way back there, I smile.
Are they fighting the horde?
Oh, they are.
Okay, I can wait.
I can't wait.
Never mind.
Maybe they'll kill each other.
Who knows?
Okay, that's fine.
I'll just wait.
I can wait a little.
Yeah, I'm letting them fight.
I'm trying to make sure if they'll hit me or not.
Okay, I don't know.
Do I go left?
I guess I go left side.
Paying attention to the missiles.
God, why are the missiles locking on me, though?
Like, why is it on me?
I don't understand.
Why?
Why is it on me?
Okay.
Yeah, I'll go run this way.
I have to run to the left.
I got to run to the left and hope they don't see me.
Oh, my God.
It wasn't to the left.
Where do I go?
Oh, my God.
Oh, fuck.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
Oh, fuck.
Yes.
I only have two shots, though.
Oh, and then I missed.
And then I missed.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where did I drop my pistol?
Oh, I don't know where I dropped the pistol.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Where do I go?
Do I go to the right?
I don't know where to go.
Oh, my God.
I'm going back.
It's dodging the riots.
I don't know where to go.
The arrow takes me back.
What do you mean?
It says go back.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I know.
I need to take them down.
I actually don't trust myself.
I don't trust myself.
I need to take them all down.
I can't.
Guys.
I know I'll die.
I...
I know.
Guys, I can't.
I'm going back.
Don't trust myself.
I feel like the mo...
Guys, the moment I grab the banshee, the moment I grab a banshee, the fucking thing is gonna, like...
It's gonna, like, come back and, like, it's a shoot me out of the sky.
We don't gamble here.
I can tell they're gonna shoot me into the sky.
I...
I feel it.
Oh, my God.
Where's the rocket?
Rocket man.
Give me your rocket.
Okay, where's two more rockets?
I need two more.
Alright, here we go.
They're gonna shoot me down.
I can feel it.
I know they're gonna...
That's the...
I know they're gonna shoot me down.
Alright, here we go.
I'm hungry.
Guys, how much more do I get...
Of this game do I have?
I might order food.
I'm hungry.
Alright.
I now have ten shots.
Two more?
Okay.
Alright.
Maxine, you feel like intervention ran.
No, Doki.
You can't get help.
Get in the banshee.
I don't trust myself.
Wings!
There we go.
Okay, one down.
There's no way it's gonna move.
Did it move?
Oh my god.
He moved.
He actually moved.
Oh my god.
That freak.
Okay.
I'm gonna get rid of all of them first.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
I will use this.
Oh my god.
There's more?
Oh.
No.
Oh no.
Oh no, I don't have a pistol.
Oh my god.
I don't have a pistol, guys.
This is bad.
Guys, this is bad.
I didn't realize.
That they're there.
Okay, this is faster.
Like, actually.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, nice nade.
Nice nade.
I didn't think I'd hit those.
Alright.
There's so many of them.
Get out of here!
Leave!
Oh my god.
How did the flood lose to them?
How did the flood lose to these guys?
Oh my god.
I can't believe the flood lost to them.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
We'll just slowly go in.
this
is fine.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
be Office 3 Go go go!
He is not okay right now.
I am NOT okay are you fucking kidding me oh my god noooo
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, okay, okay, I'm okay, oh my god, get in here, get in here, get in here, get in here, get in here, oh my god, we did it, we made it, we made it, we made it, oh my god,
we made it, we actually made it.
Holy shit.
I don't know how.
Oh, no.
I don't have ammo anymore.
Oh, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Okay.
I don't!
I have one bullet!
There you go.
Are you happy?
Last thing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, use the blast!
Oh, my one fucking bullet!
What?!
Cindy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I cannot believe she fumbled in a Banshee.
Air superiority!
My Banshee was 2 HP!
I don't know what you want from me!
I...
Oh, my God.
John Halo is not John-ing... not Halo-ing very well.
Did he TP me?
Oh, my God.
I did it.
That... that was one level?!
That...
That was two hours!
...interference from the cruiser's damaged reactor.
I'll bring us in as close as I can.
Captain Keys, help me.
I'm like...
Alright...
Don't worry Keys!
I'm coming!
Oh.
Hopefully, we needed that, actually.
All right.
We're invisible.
Ha ha ha!
He doesn't know I'm invisible!
All right.
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay, I need this gun.
Get me out of here.
Uh...
There you go.
I need... Come on.
Oh, wait!
Is it full ammo?
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
We go this way.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Yeah, what do I do?
Okay, so we have to go a different way.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Warning.
Threat level increasing.
That's fine.
I have nades.
Oh!
That jump into the coolant is looking better all the time.
Yeah, they're jumping.
Okay.
Trust me, it's deep enough to push an hour fall.
Is it?
I could make it!
I thought... Oh, shit!
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna say.
Oh, my God.
I can't see anything.
Oh, my God!
Please!
We're both not on the same team!
Let's get out of here and find another way back.
Why me?
Oh, wait.
It's time.
Oh, I can see now.
Okay.
All right.
Now, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can see though.
Okay, guys.
Give me a sec.
I need to be able to see.
Let me see for like one second.
And then...
Okay.
Okay, now we can do it.
Now...
Now we can leave.
I just wanna make sure there's any health packs.
Look, it was very dark.
Okay?
It was...
It was very, very dark.
All right.
So unnatural.
What the fuck?
Wait, what was the point of here?
What?
I killed everything.
What would work?
Go here?
What the fuck?
Here?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
Figure it out.
I got lost.
Everything looked the same.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That was not...
I didn't mean to do that actually.
That was the one time I did not mean to do that.
I wanna get rid of this guy first.
I really can't be bothered.
I know I shouldn't waste my ammo there.
But like, I can't be bothered.
You're so annoying.
You're so annoying!
Pop!
Okay, here.
Here.
Ah!
I'm sorry!
I got scared!
Sometimes when I'm scared, I press tab.
There you go.
You're fucking kidding me?
Oh, I'm running out of ammo right now.
I am...
I am running out of a lot of ammo.
I think the worst part is just the...
Oh, I don't...
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Your mom doesn't love you.
Give me that pistol.
Get out of here.
Pop!
Alright, let's see.
There we go.
They just...
Oh my god, they're endless.
I just realized they're endless.
Oh my god.
They'll keep coming.
Oh my god!
Fuck it.
That's actually not fair.
That was actually not fair.
Alright.
Like, they made no sound at all!
They just was like...
Peekaboo!
We should head this way.
To force the ship's gravity.
AHHHHH!
I swear to god.
I will press tap.
I...
Actually, no.
I should...
Like, let them do their own fight.
I can't see nothing.
The crash did more damage than I suspected.
I'm just gonna...
I'm letting them deal with this.
I'm just gonna let them deal with this.
No, it's fine.
I'm gonna let them fight this.
Like, fuck this.
I'm gonna let them fight.
What?
What does this look like?
Oh my god.
I can...
This is forever.
Are they still alive?
Is this...
Is this endless?
Will the hunters live forever?
There's no way.
AHHHHH!
I just wanted to kill the hunters.
That's all.
No, there's no way.
See, I told you.
Oh my god.
He's still trying to kill me.
Like...
There's...
There's like 200 of them.
No.
This guy died.
The other one died.
Are they actually...
No.
See, look at him.
Bro, I'm pretty sure he's dead.
I'm...
I'm pretty sure...
That guy's dead.
That guy looks so dead.
Like, there's no...
You guys were like...
Doki.
What?
The hunters are immune.
No.
I'm pretty sure they're fucking dead.
Guys.
I'm...
Oh no.
Guys, there's no more shotgun ammo.
There's no more shotgun ammo.
I'm scared.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I can watch again.
It's okay.
We'll wait.
Oh, we'll wait.
Alright.
We can...
We can wait.
Wait, what the fuck?
You see that guy?
How did he get up here?
Okay.
I'm gonna get this guy off the cliff.
Jesus Christ.
Wait.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna cause the explosion.
There we go.
Holy shit.
Look at him go.
Boom!
How is there a guy up here?
Yeah, but I want the hunters to be dead.
I need the hunters to die first.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
He's dead.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
He climbed up!
Oh my god.
Just in case.
Okay.
I just wanna be sure.
There we go.
I know you're still people there.
Just in case.
I just wanna be sure.
Okay.
Okay, checkpoint done.
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Alright.
My god.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew there's always one more.
There's always one more.
I knew.
I knew there was one more.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Jesus Christ.
Hello?
Alright.
Oh my god.
What is this?
What is this music?
Oh, I don't like this song.
Oh, I def- I don't like this song.
This song is too scary.
Too freaky for me.
Too scary for me.
Okay.
Too spooky.
Oh.
The scary violin.
Not the violin.
Oh.
That's what you know is aliens.
Okay.
Hold your position until the lift activates.
Whoa.
Holy shit.
Wait.
What the fuck.
Oh my god.
Where did he come from?
Like, actually, where did he come from?
Okay.
Did it activate?
I fucking knew it.
I knew you were dead.
I'm still here.
Okay, we need that, actually.
I gotta climb the pillar?
Okay.
All right, we gotta climb the...
Oh my god, it's not even usable.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh,
I did it!
Oh, I held it!
Yay!
Oh my god, I held it.
I didn't even realize.
I didn't even realize it's been held already.
I thought I was... I thought it was over.
I thought... I thought it was gonna...
There was gonna... More people are gonna come up.
Oh my god, get out of here.
Oh, at least I can see now.
I can actually see.
Hello?
Oh, that's a lot of dead things.
Oh, that's a lot of dead aliens.
Give me your shotgun.
Give me your shotgun!
Okay.
Oh, I know I have to go downstairs.
I know.
It's all waiting for me.
Okay, but what's over here, though?
Oh, just pop.
Okay, but what's over here?
Oh, shit!
Shotgun!
That's what's over here.
Oh, fuck!
More shotgun.
That's okay.
Okay, maybe I'm gonna go the other side.
Just in case.
Okay, that was nothing.
I thought...
I literally thought that was where I should have gone.
Alright, that's fine.
At least I got shotgun.
Actually, I am not letting these take my overshield.
Okay.
Just gotta be sure.
What?!
Oh my god, they...
Stop!
Oh my god, it's never ending.
I didn't realize that was never ending.
I thought it would end.
Oh, I wasted my overshield.
Okay, sometimes they just stop.
Sometimes they have stopped.
How was I supposed to know?
This was one of those times that they don't stop.
Okay.
No!
You fucking bitch!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I just really need them to not go up to me.
Okay.
It's fine.
Hello?
What?
Oh..
Oh my...
OH MY GOD!
I deserve that.
I deserve dying to that.
That was honestly... no, no, I... I 100% deserve that.
At least... at least... Oh, thank god.
You know, that's fine.
I'll take that.
I'll take those.
Is it here?
No, okay.
I have to go... okay, that's good.
That's good.
I still have my overshield.
And then we just go down.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
My mouse bugged out there.
Oh my god.
I forgot about these guys.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Jesus Christ, I'm stuck in the corner!
Oh my God!
Oh my God, how are you still alive?
Okay, okay, let's just make sure... we kill them first.
Okay, and then just to be sure...
Okay.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I knew your asses were there.
Oh my God, you're still alive.
Okay.
That's fine.
I can recharge.
I'll recharge my shield.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Okay, worth.
That's what I got!
Run!
Get your ass out of here!
Okay, nice.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, sh... wait!
What?!
They came by... Okay, that's cheating!
That's cheating!
Oh my God!
That's actually not fair!
That's actually... they came right behind me!
They flanked me!
I wasn't ready for the flank!
I was not ready for the flank!
Oh, whoops.
I mean, that's fine.
What the fuck?!
They did it again?!
Oh no.
Oh my God.
We
should be able to reach the control room on the third level.
Please tell me there's a checkpoint done.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please tell me there's a checkpoint done.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, not the hunter!
Not- Okay, we gotta- No, no, no!
I don't- I don't have a pistol!
I don't have a pistol!
I don't have-
Oh no.
I don't have a pistol.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Thank god.
Please tell me.
I don't know where to go.
Oh my god, you guys were a dead end?
Oh, thank god.
Thank god.
Fight.
That's good.
Fight!
Keep fighting!
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's good.
Okay.
At least they fought.
Oh.
Okay.
We made it.
We made it downstairs.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do with them upstairs.
How do I get them off?
Wrong way!
Okay.
I'm lost.
I'm so lost.
I'm actually so lost.
What way do I have to go?
Okay, this way.
But I fought so many!
I fought so many, though.
I'm just gonna make sure these guys don't bother me.
Are you jiggle peeking?
Oh.
I'm healing my shields?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, shit!
Hello.
Are you serious?
I don't...
Okay, he's off.
Alright, I need your gun.
Fuck.
Oh.
Is that your gun?
Oh my god.
Please!
I need your gun!
No!
I wasted so much ammo!
Oh my god.
Okay, I got your gun.
Got your gun!
He he.
Alright, up we go.
Up we go.
Why are you...
Oh my god.
They're running away from the flood.
They're so pathetic.
They're actually so pathetic.
TURN AROUND!
Turn your ass around!
Okay.
Oh my god.
You grunts.
Get this way.
Fucking knew it.
I heard you.
I knew it!
I knew you were there!
Okay.
Oh wait.
He has a shotgun.
I need that.
Fucking idiot.
I knew you were gonna turn around.
I'm so healthy!
I feel so healthy!
Why is there a ship?
Oh my god.
Why do I hit your ship?
Is that my ship?
Te-teammates?
Team?
Is that...
Friends?
I don't know if that was friends or not.
I can't tell.
Wait what?
Oh I...
I can't tell if they're friends.
What the fuck?
He just walks up!
Friend?
Any...
Amigos?
Captain.
Sorry!
Okay!
Look Cortana!
I am going through a lot right now Cortana!
Like...
I am trying!
Please!
There's so many of them!
Alright.
We go left or forward?
I think here, maybe?
There's no more arrows, so I can't tell.
Oh yeah, we're definitely going there.
Okay.
Alright, that's good to know.
Jesus Christ!
There's so many!
Please!
The elevator keeps opening!
I got...
The elevator...
It keeps opening!
He's?
Are you in there?
Oh my god!
It's Kerrigan!
Kerrigan?
Oh my god!
Is he gonna be sexy now?
Oh, he...
Oh...
Oh, that's not sexy.
We gotta end it.
End his misery.
Oh...
Oh my god!
His head!
It's still breathing!
He's still alive, guys!
He's still breathing!
Don't you hear that?
Oh my god!
I like...
Punched his face in...
Oh shit!
Whoops!
I got a little too distracted.
Jesus Christ!
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec!
Oh my god.
I need to re...
I need to heal my shield real quick too.
Alright.
The Flood did not like that.
No, they definitely did not.
They were really angry with me with that.
What the fuck?
He's just standing there.
Alright, get out.
Oh!
Okay, I did not expect that.
I actually did not expect that.
Oh my god.
Please.
I have so many things to deal with.
Oh my god.
Okay.
To recharge my shields.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
We need to get back to the Pillar of Autumn.
Go back to the Shuttleway and find your ride.
That's...
Fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so messed up.
That's messed up, buddy.
I need your but...
I need your buddy, friend.
Oh my god.
How am I doing worse?
How am I actually...
Oh my...
Just end me.
Just get me out of here.
Wait, maybe if I... I know.
Fight each other.
Yes!
Oh, I'm so smart!
Oh, shit!
There we go.
I can sit here.
That's right!
Entertainment!
Me!
Don't worry.
I'll come in a third party later.
That's lucky, right?
Don't worry.
I'm here in a third party.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
I think they won.
Oh, yeah.
No.
They definitely won.
Alright.
Let's go through.
Nice.
That's good.
Here?
Do I go all the way back?
I'm so lost.
Do I backtrack?
Oh, back where I came from.
Okay.
Back here.
This is where I came from.
And then I came here.
Oh, there you go.
I figured it out, guys.
I did it.
Okay.
God, these guys... Oh, I'm just gonna let them pop.
They're so annoying.
They're actually so annoying.
Oh, my God.
They took my fucking... Oh, my God.
Really?
I didn't see the name.
Oh, my God.
I actually... I didn't see it.
I swear to God.
I... If it hits me again.
I swear to fucking God.
Oh, my God.
I learned my lesson.
I heard... I saw the wind-up.
I saw the wind-up.
I saw that wind-up.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
That's right.
Oh my god.
He's a fucking baseball player.
Holy shit.
He's gaming.
Are you serious?
You're still here?
Are you fucking... I hate you.
I hate you.
Oh my... Get out of here.
Oh my god.
I hate him.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Bro, they're actual baseball players.
Like, somebody draft him right now.
What?
Someone actually draft this man.
Oh my god.
You fuckers.
They must get on you.
Okay.
I swear to god.
Where are you?
I know you're alive.
It's gonna find you.
I told I was close.
Oh, that was so close.
Oh, you almost got me.
You almost did it.
That was a little too close for comfort.
No, it was.
It was 100% too close for comfort.
Is he dead?
Okay, thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Where do I...
Oh, I have to go all the way down.
Don't I?
Oh, how do I get down?
How do I...
Wait, can I jump here?
Can I jump on that ship?
I can jump down?
I...
Okay.
Okay, that was like a little too intense for me.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I...
I don't...
That's it!
Wee...
I can't.
I...
Wee...
Okay, you guys could have told me that that was the end of the level.
I would have...
If I knew that doing that ends the level, I would have done that earlier, chat.
If I knew that, I would have done that earlier.
I thought... I thought... I don't know.
I thought I'd die if I do it.
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He really was a baseball player.
Three strikes and you're out.
Yeah, the Dodgers should have signed this guy up.
It's okay.
Captain Fuse will get better, right, guys?
He'll get better.
Just a little flesh wound.
His head can grow back.
Guys, I...
You did that on purpose, didn't you?
Did I live?
Oh, now?
Oh, so now he lives through explosions.
But all the other times...
It's like credits.
All the other times I don't live, but this time I live...
Alright, I need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm angry.
Wow, I'm back.
Uh...
Min!
Robin!
Wyatt!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Uh...
Stick of Butter!
Nexi!
Mike!
Pawn!
Zekra!
Solid!
Neppers!
Medi!
Bite!
Bowen!
Alan!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh...
Ping!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna order food then.
If this is the last level, let me order food in advance.
Okay, ordering food time.
Alright.
It's like when you feed a Haru grass.
What do I want to eat today, though?
I haven't had, like, takeout for a bit.
So I don't know.
Alright, guys.
Uh...
Ooh!
What's this?
Have I tried this before?
Ooh!
Truffle?
That's bougie as fuck!
Nah, I don't really want Truffle.
Uh...
Ooh!
There's a new place!
Called...
Wait, why?
I shouldn't say...
I was like, called?
Whoa!
Let me dox myself real quick, sorry!
You don't know what it's called?
I don't know what it's called, guys.
I...
Let's see...
I don't know.
I don't know what I want to eat.
Hmm...
I've had a tie in a long ass time, to be fair.
Uh...
Oh!
Summer outfit time!
Yeah, I can, Nexy!
Thank you, Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Um...
Oh, it's...
Oh, yeah, it's time to swap the outfit.
Okay, after I pick my food, guys...
Oh!
I could get...
Mmm...
Do I want sushi today?
I could get sushi...
No, I had sushi...
Last time I went out to eat, I had sushi already.
So I should get something different.
Uh...
Mmm...
I haven't had a tie in a long ass time.
Maybe?
Let me check.
Ooh...
Ooh, I could get fried rice.
Uh...
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to pick, guys.
I'm so hungry.
Mmm...
So hungry.
Uh...
Yeah, get day three ready.
Fudge tap.
You're in a Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, I know what to get.
Alright, I'm gonna get...
Uh...
A burger?
No, no burger.
Not burger.
I'm gonna get...
Uh...
I'm gonna get a Vietnamese place.
But like, not pho.
Because I don't like...
I personally...
Ooh...
That one...
Let me add...
Add this to it.
I personally don't like...
Uh...
I don't like...
Anything with...
No, I like pho.
But I don't like takeout pho.
You know?
I think takeout pho is not as good...
Compared to like...
Eating at the place.
Yeah, I love pho.
I just don't like doing takeout for it.
Yeah, it's just not the same.
But I do like other Vietnamese cuisines that you can takeout.
So I'm fine with that.
Yeah.
That's what I mean.
Don't keep fresh grass bun.
I am pho.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I like eating pho at the restaurant.
I don't want to eat it like...
Um...
From takeout.
It's just not the same.
Let's see.
What's this?
Ooh...
Trying to figure out what to get.
I should get the...
Hmm...
I'm gonna get lychee juice.
I love the...
I love lychee.
And I love...
Wait, do you have dragon eye?
Longan?
Oh, they don't have dragon eye.
Um...
You guys ever want to try like...
Uh...
An Asian type of fruit?
Dragon eye is so good.
Or longan.
It's so good.
It's like...
It's like really sweet.
Alright, I'm gonna try...
I'm gonna try...
I never tried this.
It's fried noodles.
I never tried it before.
Oh, wait.
What should I do?
Okay, guys.
Do I get noodles or...
Actually, I've been having a lot of noodles.
I'll get fried rice.
Let's see.
Yeah, I'll add this.
I've been eating a lot of noodles recently.
No, I never tried durian.
Not really like...
A huge...
Fan of durian in general.
Or...
I could get...
Hmm...
Alright.
I ordered what I want.
I got...
I got fried rice.
Alright.
I'm treating myself.
Treat yourself.
Wait.
Go back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Leave at my door, please.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I just ordered food.
Yeah.
Okay.
When does it arrive?
Nice.
Alright.
It's time.
The final level.
Holy shit.
I can't believe it.
That...
The last level was two hours.
The first level was two hours long.
Come there.
We can
eat.
The explosion should damage enough systems below it to destroy the bridge.
I'm so lost.
Make your way to the bridge.
Does anyone have the map?
Of course.
Of fucking course.
Oh, the s- oh wait, sorry.
I forgot about the outfit swap.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Like...
Uh...
Well, no.
That's the...
Thank you for reminding me.
Let me swap real fast.
Alright.
Uh...
I'm going to my claws and changing clothes real quick.
Let me swap my clothes real quick, guys.
Alright.
Uh...
Buh buh buh buh buh buh buh.
Oh my god.
My stuff is like all...
Okay.
I have to like redo every...
Not...
Okay.
Not redo everything, but...
Alright.
Here we go.
And then...
Buh buh buh buh.
Let's see.
Gone.
Alright.
And then...
What's this?
Okay.
This...
Alright.
Actually...
No.
I can just take this off.
There we go.
Alright.
Got my gun out now.
Now.
I'm ready.
I have a gun.
Alright.
Back from the closet.
Whoops.
Clicked the wrong thing.
Oh my god.
I'm clicking so many.
I'm like all over the place.
I'm clicking all...
Alright.
Now I'm actually locked in.
I'm locked in now.
Alright.
Okay.
I think they're all done exploding.
Good.
I was gonna...
I swear to god.
If they're...
If they're still exploding, I...
Okay.
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here!
That's fucking right!
I have the gun now!
Okay.
I assume it's...
It's not this way.
Oh my god.
Just explode on me.
I don't care.
I...
Oh shit.
I care about these guys though.
Oh my god.
Okay.
These guys take forever to die.
This is bad.
Oh, I need shotguns.
Really badly.
Oh, where are the shotguns?
Oh!
Ah!
He's jumping to wipe me!
Okay, it's fine.
Holy shit.
The music is so loud.
Is the music okay?
Cause it seems really loud on my end.
I...
Okay, you can just explode.
Yeah, this BGM is loud!
Okay.
Okay, it's a bit loud.
Okay, I'll turn it down a little bit.
Oh my god.
I'll turn it down a little bit.
Yeah, audio.
Is it game music?
Okay, it was.
Okay.
I'll do it 90.
90.
There we go.
Oh my god.
I don't know if that fixes anything.
I...
I don't know.
Okay, just explode.
Just pop.
That's right.
Very good.
Are you happy little guy?
Are you happy?
Alright, sound guy.
I know you're here.
Is the music blow bet...
Is it better now?
Alright.
There we go.
Wait.
I hear him.
I...
Oh my god.
I hear them.
Go fight.
Let's fight.
Oh my god.
Go fight.
Woo!
Oh my god.
That was an accident.
That's fine.
Oh that is not fine.
Okay.
We're okay.
I...
I gave an act...
It's fine.
We gave him a little back shot.
That's so...
Oh my god.
I'm not fine anymore.
I'm...
I'm not fine anymore, guys.
I am absolutely not fine anymore.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh ho ho ho ho.
Okay.
There we go.
It's okay.
We killed 50 hunters.
Oh my god.
We did it.
And we grabbed this too.
Okay.
I'll do the music a little less.
I'll put an 80.
Let me know if it's better, sound guy.
No.
Don't you...
Oh my god.
It's him.
It's baseball man.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No.
They can't do this to me.
He can't do this to me.
He's back.
He's actually back.
Oh my god.
This is my checkpoint.
This is my hell.
This is actually my checkpoint.
Wait, this is... This is my help.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I don't know how I'm gonna survive this.
Of course this is where it took me.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Last nade.
Okay, we got him.
Are you all dead?
Oh, I see you.
Oh, you pretend... You put me in a false sense of security.
You got me out of cover!
You do!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm so sad.
I'm so... I'm so sad.
He baseballed me.
He baseballed me!
He actually baseballed me!
Oh my god, you fucker!
He's actually... He's such a fucker.
He's such a fucker!
I'm playing dodgeball right now.
I'm actually playing dodgeball.
With them.
Oh my god.
How many nades!
How many nades did this mad throw!
How fucking...
How many!
Holy shit!
At...
It has...
They threw so many at me!
It was actually crazy!
Oh my god...
Oh.
My God.
Holy shit!
Bro, sign him up!
I bet he'll get paid more playing baseball than this.
Bro, get your million dollar contract!
Bro, what you doing here?
You're... Seriously, get out of the military!
Oh my god, that's so close.
You're wasting your skills here!
The Dodgers would have won if you... The Dodgers would have won if you were there!
Oh my god.
What, what, what?
Alright, here you go.
I swear to...
Oh my god, we both threw our...
More, more, more.
I think the Yankees need him more.
Holy fuck, I swear to god.
I was gonna say, if that actually got me...
Oh my god, this is the most intense 1v1 right now.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho!
The most fucking intense 1v1.
Oh my god, these little guys were just watching this entire time.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho!
Okay.
Yeah, we go this way.
Okay, we don't go this way.
They respected the 1v1.
Oh, thank god.
The bridge.
We made it.
Let's get to work.
I saw...
Is this all you do?
Is this really all you do every day?
Every fucking day, this is all you do!
Oh my god.
The fucking drive-by.
Okay.
I mean, it worked, though.
What the fuck?
I need you to upload me into the control systems.
The terminal is located next to the main view screen.
Oh, there you go.
Forgot you have a flashlight, didn't you?
Okay, I...
What was I gonna use the flashlight on for?
Wait, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Would have gone pro if you didn't join the Navy.
Wait, that's out of the question, really.
Oh, hell.
Oh my god, he's back.
Stupid.
3-4-3.
He's in my data arrays.
A local tap.
Oh my god, he's in our heads.
Can't imagine how exciting this is.
To have a record of all of our lost time.
Human history, is it?
Fascinating.
Get out of my head!
Oh, man!
Oh, how I will enjoy every moment of its categorization.
To think that you would destroy this installation as well as this record.
I am shocked.
Almost too shocked for words.
He stopped the self-destruct sequence.
No!
Not timed!
At least I still have control over the comm channels.
Where is he?
I'm detecting taps throughout the ship.
Sentinels most likely.
S for the monitor.
He's in engineering.
He must be trying to take the core offline.
Even if I could get the countdown restarted.
I don't know what to do.
How much firepower would you need to crack one of the engine's shields?
Not much.
A well-placed grenade perhaps, but why?
Oh, I have one!
Yay!
I can place it in a well-placed area.
Just chuck it, right?
No, please.
Oh, no!
No!
My shield!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
That's fine.
I just wanna get rid of them first before we go.
Alright, nice.
Where do I go?
Oh.
Oh, this way.
Oh, it was this way.
Okay.
Um.
Ah!
Follow my heart!
My heart doesn't know where to go!
Where's the yellow paint?
Where is it?
Yellow paint!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're back!
Okay, at least- At least they're here to tell me where to go.
Oh my god, does it not stop?
Okay.
Thank god.
Thank god they're here to tell me where to go.
That's everything I needed.
Okay, I'll just wait here until- Until they come in here.
Fucking baseball.
Oh my god, they have to go straight- Oh!
Oh my god, they have to go straight- Okay.
Oh!
Bye.
I didn't know that was where I had to go.
I thought I had to fight some- Oh!
The fight.
Hello.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I'm run- I am running out of the alien gun.
So I'm gonna- Gonna save that a little bit.
Oh wait, never mind.
JK.
I don't have to save it.
Whoops.
Guys!
Babies!
Please!
There is bigger- Bigger fish to fry!
Alright, this way.
Nice.
Alright.
Not nice.
We'll let them deal with each other.
I'll wait.
I can wait.
I- I can wait.
Are they- Are they still fighting?
Oh!
Are they- Are they done?
So how's the weather?
Okay.
Let me get rid of these guys first.
Okay, now I can come in.
Hello, guys!
Hello, everybody!
Wow!
Can't believe everybody just died like that.
Huh.
Just...
Nice.
Don't have to do much work after that.
So conf- Oh, whoop, whoop.
What the- Okay, okay.
Oh no, they're- They're ganging up on each other.
Oh no, I'm getting ganging up on.
I'm getting ganging up on.
Alright, I'm going in.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I have to go this way.
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Just gonna let it explode here.
Oh no, that's not good.
Okay.
Oh, this is a push hallway?!
God dammit!
Oh ho ho ho my god!
I did it!
No, it's infinite!
Be different!
It's not self-explanatory!
Okay.
Sometimes- Sometimes they're not infinite!
Sometimes they just stop!
Alright, this way.
Oh!
Oh my god, he was running away from them.
Oh my god!
Oh, please tell me I- Oh!
Please stop!
We have to go this way!
Alright, that's fine.
I-I didn't need those shits.
I-I didn't need it.
Wait, what?
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh, we live here now, I guess.
I can live here.
Do you think they know?
Did they- did they kill them?
Did they do it?
I don't know if they did it.
I don't know.
Are you doing it?
It's very quiet outside.
He naided me.
He- He naided me.
He actually naided me.
He got the naid off.
He got the fucking naid off!
He got the naid off!
Fuck you!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill this one guy.
I need to kill this guy.
Oh my god, he almost hit me.
Like, I need him to die.
Just him.
Like, I just want him to be dead.
Like, I don't care.
I'm gonna go straight down.
Oh, Armory.
Yeah?
Wait, I need the rocket?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, why is he invisible?
Why are they invisible?!
Oh my god.
Why were they invisible?
Why- why were they invisible?
I don't understand.
I-
I don't- I don't know where the invisible weapon is.
The voices are fighting back.
I'm trying to find the rocket logic.
I'm so confused and- Oh, there we go.
Okay.
I found it.
What's this invisible secret weapon?
I don't know what you mean.
Oh shit.
No.
What the fuck did I- Okay.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I'm ready.
The flood- Oh my god.
The flood was a secret weapon.
Oh my god.
You guys are fuckers.
You guys- I'm okay.
Light fuse run away.
Is it here?
Located.
We're here.
Alert.
The monitor has disabled all command access.
We can't restore the counter.
The only convenient option is to detonate the ship's fusion reactors.
That should do enough damage to destroy Halo.
Don't worry.
I have access to all of the reactor schematics and procedures.
I'll walk you through it.
First, we need to pull back the exhaust couplings.
That will expose a shaft that leads to the primary fusion- What the fuck are all these arrows?
Okay, it's infinite.
Okay.
The blockades will be removed in 16 cycles.
Oh my god.
There's so many arrows on my screen.
Oh my god, they-
Okay, I was not expecting two of them to-
Where?
This?
Oh my god, I don't know what that is.
Is it this?
Oh my god.
I'm so confused.
The arrow?
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
There we go.
Okay, I get it.
I get it now.
Oh my god.
Use the controls on the- Okay, checkpoint done.
Okay, I have to do that three more times.
Okay, I get it.
What?
Oh my god.
It's the- Oh my god!
He had grenades on him.
It triggered like a fucking- Oh my god.
It triggered a chemical reaction.
Stupid grenade chain.
I was like so confused.
It's like, what happened?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I thought I was gonna-
Where's Sierra?
Oh my god!
What
happened?
Is it- Are you serious?
What happened?
He actually- Oh my god.
He jumped into the... Oh my god!
He jumped into my rocket!
Oh my god!
I can't believe he fucking bought it!
That was sick and crazy!
I can't believe that!
That was actually crazy!
Oh my god, that was crazy!
It was so bullshit that that actually happened, too!
Oh my god!
That's actually crazy!
Come on!
Come on, come on!
What the fuck?!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Oh my god!
The rocket doesn't hit it!
It doesn't let me aim it at there!
Okay.
Oh my god.
The worst part is because, like, is the, um...
Because I don't... I don't have the alien gun.
I hate... Oh my god, the little guys.
Jesus Christ!
Let me breathe!
Get out!
I... Oh, I'm fucking just going in.
I'm going straight in.
Fuck this.
Okay.
I hate this part.
This part sucks.
This part fucking sucks!
All right.
All right, we'll try this again.
I'm going to try to nade.
It's a little... It's a... Guys, it's these guys.
It's these guys.
These guys are so annoying.
Because I don't have my alien gun.
I'm going to try this again.
Okay.
Am I
open up?
Open up!
The flood continues to multiply.
I...
Oh my god!
How do I throw this?
Okay.
That works.
Fuck it.
I'll take that.
I'll take it.
Where's the last one?
We must keep moving.
The Dodgers.
I never said I'd be in the Dodgers, guys.
I'm so sad.
Wait.
How do I... Okay.
I have to get to the other side.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Is it this way?
Oh, it's this way.
Are you serious?
Where the fuck did you come from?
Okay.
All right.
This one was easier.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Why?
Oh my god.
There's so many of you guys.
Get out of here.
Get out.
Why?
Why were you all just bunched up here?
Oh my god.
How do I get...
How do I get there?
Wait.
How do I get to that side?
Oh my god.
I have to climb all the way back.
I could have parkoured?
I'm gonna try to parkour.
I...
I'm gonna try.
I don't care.
Let him come in.
I'm gonna try parkouring.
I don't care.
All right.
Oh.
Give me a sec.
Give me down!
That's on me.
That was on me.
I'm fucking...
I...
Okay.
I'm a little tilted.
I'm...
I don't know if that's noticeable.
I'm a little tilted.
Oh my god.
I can't.
These little fucking popcorn fuckers.
I can't focus.
Okay.
Oh my god.
How did I first try this?
Okay.
I...
It's okay.
I can do this.
I'm so...
I'm so fucking...
Okay.
Like this is it.
This is it.
I can do this.
Okay.
Now how the fuck do I...
Oh my god.
I give up.
I'm gonna die.
I'm actually gonna die.
Oh my god, I'm actually gonna die.
I give up.
Give me your last health back.
I can't.
I fucking can't.
I'm gonna walk all the way up.
I can't, I can't do this anymore.
I can't do this anymore.
I know that I can't.
There's too much anger in me.
There's too much... I know what crouch jumping is!
I do!
I'm just too angry.
I'm too angry to do it.
I... I'm just...
I have too much hate inside me.
I... There's too much hate, guys.
I can't.
There we go.
Oh, get off the ship!
Oh my god.
I don't remember how to leave.
There's a service corridor that runs along the ship's dorsal structure.
Hurry!
Where?
It's on the third floor!
Okay.
Let's go back up.
Let's go back up to the third floor.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go this way, apparently.
Alright.
It's on the third floor.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
At least... I could've crossed.
It's okay.
I... Sometimes life be like that.
Sometimes... There's just so much hate in me.
It's... I'm not okay.
I'm not okay.
I am not okay, chat.
I am absolutely not okay.
After that parkour.
Alright.
We're... We're making it.
Oh thank god there's arrows.
Thank fucking god.
Get me out of here.
Oh my god.
I've been through so much.
You can't do this to me.
Wait.
What?
Matt.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
I can't... I was... I had so much hate in me.
I just couldn't jump anymore.
One more.
No.
We have a wildcat destabilization of the ship's fusion core.
The engines must have sustained more damage than we thought.
Analyze.
We have six minutes before the fusion drives density.
You need to be backwards.
Get me out of here.
Please.
I must make it past this.
Just keep driving!
Weeeeeee!
1 point.
Just head straight.
They can't stop me if I just keep going straight.
They can't stop me.
No!
Oh my god!
I went the wrong back and see- I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
I'm so okay.
I'm okay right now.
I'm not.
Alright.
Just keep driving.
It's a good thing I didn't panic, guys.
Thank god.
Thank god I didn't panic, chat.
Thank- Oh my god!
Oh my- Just shoot me more!
Shoot me more!
Surely something will happen.
Okay, here we go.
We made it to this side.
Here we go.
Wee!
What do you mean loading done?
What else is there to load for me?
And why does it not say checkpoint done?
Why does it say loading done?
Wee!
Oh my god!
Hey guys, I'm gonna go this way now.
I'll figure out.
Oh my god.
Guys, give me a sec.
I'll figure out how to get through this area.
Holy shit!
There's so many explosives!
Oh my god!
There's so many explosives, everyone!
Wee!
Please help me!
This is the final area!
Wee!
Wait, stop!
This is where Fohhammer is coming to pick us up!
Hold position here!
Hello?
Cortana to Echo 419!
Two Covenant Banshees are approaching on your 6!
Evade!
Say again!
Am I safe?
I can't tell!
Is she okay?
Oh, she was not okay.
AAAAAAAAAAicle?
One long looking Emperor of O Lord is still docked in Launch Base 7.
If we move now, we can make it.
Negative.
We have a Wildcat destabilization of the Jets-Fusion Core.
The engines must have sustained more damage than we thought.
Analyzing.
We have six minutes before the fusion drives detonate.
We need to evac now.
Activating final countdown timer.
When it reaches zero, the engines will die.
The explosion will generate a temperature of almost 100 million degrees.
Don't matter when it blows.
No!
I went so hard!
I went... Oh my god!
I did so well!
I was gaming!
I was actually gaming!
How did this happen to me?
How did... I got shot in the back!
Oh my god!
I can't believe...
I was so close!
I was so fucking close!
I fell off!
Out of my car!
I couldn't get back up!
No!
I was trying... I was trying to turn my car back forward because it flipped!
It's... Oh my god!
My car flipped just...
I didn't know I had to keep driving!
Oh my god!
It's over!
It's over for me!
I'm 2 HP!
It's over!
It's never been so over!
It's never...
I was trying to
get back up!
I was trying to get a car!
Nobody told me that was a thing!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I've never seen that happen to anyone!
Congratulations!
It was me!
At destabilization of the ship's fusion core, the engines must have sustained more damage than we thought!
Analyzing...
We have 6 minutes before the fusion drives detonate.
We need to evac now!
Activating final countdown timer!
Oh my god!
The car crushing!
The car fucking crushing!
That can happen?!
The car... The car can just...
Oh my god!
Oh!
Just kill me!
I'm 1 HP!
Just... Oh!
I just... Just get this over with!
I'm 1 HP!
Just get this over with!
Negative!
We have a wildcat destabilization of the ship's fusion core!
Oh my god!
The engines must have sustained more damage than we thought!
This is the...
You're doing the impossible!
Oh my god!
How are the runs getting worse and worse?
It's actually crazy!
The... The rage run... I do worse!
Oh my god!
I don't know how that's possible!
I don't know how I do worse every run!
I... I... I... Don't... No!
Okay.
This is fine.
This is... This is... This is not fine.
But like, this is fine.
Alright.
I...
I can't believe... I can't believe I almost first tried it!
I almost first tried it!
This is... My car!
My car!
Fucking...
I can't believe my car!
NO!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
They're all beaming me.
It's... It's like...
The fucking cancer rate!
Oh my god!
How many flips!
How many flips?!
Okay.
Okay, here you go.
There you go.
Okay, no joke.
It just keeps flipping!
What do I do?
It just keeps flipping.
One more flip for the road.
What?
Oh my god.
Please just fuck me, I guess.
It was like, nice flip.
You know I'm playing Tony Hawk's pro skateboard right now.
That's what I'm playing.
Tony Hawk's skateboard.
Let's go.
Alright.
Weeeeee!
Alright, don't make it.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Hey.
Hey, everyone.
Oh, why did I go that way?
I don't know.
I don't know why.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, get me in here.
Alright.
Oh, we got work.
We have one more.
Oh my god, we're here.
Loading that I'm gonna keep driving.
I'm gonna keep driving.
No.
No!
We do not stop!
We do not stop.
Oh my god, why?
Why is my car turning like that?
Oh my god.
What is going on with my car?
Oh my god, I can't control it.
It has a mind of its own.
I can't control it anymore.
I swear.
I can't control it.
It has a mind of its own.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Don't flip.
Oh my god, am I at top speed?
Am I at top speed?
Oh my god.
Am I...
No!
Guys, I was not at top speed.
I was not at top speed.
I... I was not.
Alright.
Oh, we're so close.
We're so fucking close.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
We're almost at the freedom.
We're...
Oh, my God.
I don't... Oh, shit.
I'm going.
Oh, God.
I'm running.
Oh, don't look back.
Cool, guys.
No good.
Oh, I'm sorry for looking back.
No, no.
They can't do this to me.
Oh, shit.
I almost died.
If he shot one more bullet.
I would have been gone.
Don't stop.
Holy shit.
Almost lost it all for the bit.
Cam, thank you for the super gem.
Thank you for his try.
Oh, my God.
Did I do it?
Did I... Did I do it?
Oh, my God.
The plan exploded.
Oh, shut them down.
We'll need them later.
Oh, I
did it.
I did it.
I... I did it.
I... I lived.
Did anyone else make it?
Done it.
Johnson?
What about Johnson?
We're all that's left.
No.
Sergeant Johnson.
For Earth.
an entire covenant armada obliterated.
And the flood.
We had no choice.
Oh.
Halo.
It's finished.
No.
That's not true.
I think we're just...
Seriously?
We're just kidding.
He took his helmet off!
John Halo!
Oh my god, good timing.
The food literally came just as he took off his helmet.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
I still... I still can't believe a banshee hit me in the back.
And then my car flipped over.
And then it flipped over the bridge.
I can't...
I can't believe that happened.
Oh my god.
I got Halo backshot.
I got it.
It all worked out in the end.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We finally beat Halo 1.
Oh my god.
We're all there, guys.
We're all there.
One last backshot.
We were here.
Steven, thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you.
Good job, little bird.
Enjoy the rest of Halo.
Thank you.
Thank you for the magenta soupa.
Alright, let's swap.
Let's swap screens real quick.
Oh my god.
What a wild ride.
What a fucking wild ride.
Oh my god.
Let's swap here real quick.
That was actually...
I'm so...
That was so fucked up.
Oh wait, that's not the right one.
That's the cowboy one.
That was so fucked up.
I'm not gonna lie.
Let me put the gun down.
It's over.
Let's grab...
Grab the beach ball.
Put on the shirt.
It's time for my vacation.
Aloha.
Right?
It's right after, you know, when we fucking beat Halo 1.
John, Halo, and Cortana goes to the beach back to find space Hawaii.
John, Halo, and Cortana at the beach right now.
We're having our beach episode.
I'm just happy.
I'm happy we beat...
Yeah, it's straight to vacation time.
John, Halo, and Speedo, and Cortana, and Bikini.
And we're living the good life.
But yes, we finally finished.
Finally finished Halo 1.
I'm looking forward to try the rest of the Halo series in the future.
Yeah, Beach Party.
Beach Party with John Halo, guys!
Let's go!
Yes, I will be playing Halo 2.
I'm going to play Halo 2, Halo 3, and Halo Reach.
Apparently, that's, like, the order I should be playing.
Um, we're not going to go beyond 3 because, apparently, after 3 is not a good time.
Um, Halo 3, um, I was approached by Zentreya if, like, that she really, really wanted me to play multiplayer on Halo 3.
Because I was just going to do a solo run.
Um, but Zen messaged me and said that, uh, if Halo 3 has to be played with multiplayer.
And I was like, wait, really?
Apparently, I don't know.
Is that, is that true?
Halo 3 is meant to be, like, a four-player game.
Because, apparently, yeah, apparently, like, um, um, two of the characters in Halo 3, um, is, like, part of the story.
So, like, Zen said, like, when I start Halo 3, she wants me to get into a four-stack with her and, like, two other people.
Um, to, to experience the campaign.
And that there is friendly fire.
And, like, I'm scared.
I, I, I, because the amount of times I died to my own nades and the enemy nades.
And now, I have to be aware of, I have to be aware of my teammates' nades.
So, there is friendly fire.
Yeah.
You should be scared.
In my own car.
But anyways, um, for Halo 3, it will be multiplayer.
Uh, friend, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Uh, congratulations, Doki, for completing Halo.
Now, do Halo 2 on Lasso.
What's Lasso?
Uh, Netbase, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Now, you just need to host a LAN party with mid to complete the Halo 1 experience.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Lauren Lincoln, um, Arcturus, thank you for the super chat.
Uh, wait.
Let me grab my food real quick before I do the rest of the donation reading.
I'll be right back, guys.
Ah, I got food.
Okay, let me get my food out real quick, guys.
Ooh.
Dad knows I got food, too.
He's like, food?
You heard the sound of... Yeah.
I know you know.
Oh, I don't know if I got utensils.
I forgot to request utensils.
I hate it.
I hate that.
I always forget to request utensils.
All right, give me a sec.
I gotta... I gotta grab utensils.
He's like, food?
For me?
No, it's not for you.
Dad, it's not for you.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
It's just annoying.
It's just annoying to have to, like, you know... I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I'm grabbing utensils.
Okay.
All right.
Yay!
Okay.
I'll nom a bit while I do super chat reading.
Um, I got carpaccio, too.
I love carpaccio.
Yeah.
Um, but, um... Hmm.
Putting the sauce on.
That was fun, though.
For my first Halo experience.
It was really fun.
Um... Guys, I... I know how to crouch jump.
I was just so mad.
I was so angry.
I...
I don't understand.
I couldn't...
My brain was never... Not thinking anymore.
I was just so mad.
He's not thinking about super chat.
Thank you.
I'm too angry with jump.
I was so angry.
Um... Um... Imposter.
You didn't even super chat, didn't you think?
Yeah.
Well, Joki, now that you've finished Halo 1, are you completing you in Halo 2 or are you trying to curse Halo for the dragoons and make people laugh their lungs out?
What's curse Halo?
I saw a lot of people suggesting it, but I don't know why it is.
It's so funny.
Yeah, okay, but what... What does it do?
But, like, how is it funny?
You're not... Maybe I'll do curse Halo at the... Like, at the end of all the series.
As, like, a bonus.
You know?
Like, bonus run.
Like, an encore.
I don't know what it's for.
Oh, I think it's for my fried rice.
Maybe?
I don't know.
What is it?
Oh, they did me!
Oh, no, that's not...
Just JK.
Ooh.
Okay, let me...
Y'all evil?
Wait, I thought you guys said it was fun.
Why did this guy say that you guys are evil?
Do you mean fun for you guys?
And not fun for me?
Is that it?
I knew it.
It is fun for the audience.
Is that it?
Fun and evil.
Um, Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You don't need to play any of the story co-op.
And the characters actually have unique actions and dialogue.
You're not missing much if you are co-op.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Nineball, thank you for the super chat.
Crisela is on the Steam Workshop.
So installation is like, oh, that's good.
I like it when things are easy.
I don't want to think too much.
I want to ask when's the next collab.
Literally next week.
I've been lining up collabs for like, um, at least one, like every week.
There's one collab.
Every week.
I'm trying to, I'm trying to be like, old Doki again, where I did lots of collabs.
But I didn't do that recently for a while because I was so fucking busy.
Because I'm always the one organizing it.
Um, I really get invited.
Because like, I think like VTubers are very, a lot of VTubers are like super introverted and stuff.
And usually they don't want to...
It's hard for them to like, go outside their own like, circle.
Which is understandable.
Because, um, um, it's always hard to like, make the first step.
So like, that's why you tend to see like, a lot of like, the groups would stay within the group and stuff.
So like, yeah, take the first step.
So like, usually I'm the one reaching out to make these collabs happen.
That's why like, recently I wasn't doing that.
Like, I wasn't like, reaching out to people for collabing and stuff.
And that's why like, we didn't have collabs for a while now.
Hmm.
But like, I have time again, you know?
After hell month.
After a while to go through, um, with the concert and everything, that's over.
I have a lot more time now, to like, do that stuff.
No, I collab with, I don't just collab with VTubers.
I collab with Fleshtubers, you know?
Um, Fleshtubers are actually like, the people who love to ask me.
Like, I think Fleshtubers, since a lot of them are like, super extroverted.
That's weird.
VTubers, they're more introverts than they are.
They're like, VTubers, there's a lot of introverts for VTubing.
But for Fleshtubers, the majority of them are usually like, extroverted people.
And they're always like, asking me, asking people for collabs and stuff like that.
Because they're always doing stuff like IRL, shit like that.
They do like, IRL stuff.
They do like, um, always interacting with other streamers and stuff like that.
Um.
I do do a lot of stuff.
But when I do get invited, invited to things, it's mostly from the Fleshtubers.
Because they're all very, like, extroverted people.
Um.
Wings, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blasto stands for Legendary Difficulty All Skulls On.
You should see what skulls do in Halo to understand why this is a game type.
Usually play this in four-player co-op.
Uh, didn't, no, Sen did not.
Sen just said, whenever I start Halo 3.
Like, whenever I finish Halo 2, to just like, tell her about it.
And she was like, set up a collab.
Because I told her, like, oh, I'm still...
I still have Halo 1 and 2 to finish and stuff.
So I don't know when I'll be playing Halo 3 yet.
But she was like, okay, just let me know later.
Uh, thank you for the super chat, Wings.
Thank you, thank you.
Um.
Of course.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
This game was part of my childhood and you engaged with it perfectly.
You reacted to the story beats and fell for the dev's traps.
Not just point A to B.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart for making this journey nostalgic and enjoyable and fresh.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Yeah, that's why I wanted to do this series.
Because, like, Halo was something I've always wanted to play for the longest time.
Um, I never had perms before in the before times.
Um, because, like, I don't know.
Microsoft just never gave perms out.
Um, so, I was super...
I think they just didn't...
They didn't care.
Because Microsoft was like, why the fuck are you asking about perms?
Just play the game, you know?
Um, so, I'm really happy to actually be able to try Halo.
And I know, like, people always love watching, like, you know, first time experience.
Like, it's very rare.
It's very rare to be...
It's very rare to find, I guess, like, a streamer that's never played Halo before.
Um, especially, like, an FPS, like, streamer in general.
Because a lot of, like, you know, a lot of people who play FPS games grew up with Halo.
Or, like, no, like, grew up with Halo.
And, like, played Halo.
A lot of them came from Halo games.
But I was, like, the rare ones that didn't because my dad was a Sony boy.
So, I never got a chance to grow up with Halo at all.
So, um, it was all a new experience for me in general because of it.
Mm-hmm.
It's very rare to have those type of experience.
So, you're like, whoa!
Like, you know, I never really knew the plot point of Halo.
I just knew Cortana and John Halo.
I just knew, like, you know, the main character is that guy in the green armor.
And that's...
And then Cortana is the AI.
That's literally my knowledge of Halo.
That's all I knew.
And now I know more.
Now I know about the fucking flood.
Never knew about the fucking zombies.
Nobody told me about the zombies.
I thought that would be a very important thing that people would tell others about.
Apparently, it was not.
I was like, what the...
There's zombies in Halo?
I was so surprised when I first encountered it.
I was like, why the fuck did no one ever talk about the zombies?
Wap-up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Definitely play Halo 2 in remastered graphics.
Those cutscenes feel like you're definitely watching a movie.
Oh, is that...
Is Halo 2 cutscenes better?
Like, the graphics better for Halo 1?
Like, I like how I used the remastered graphics as, like, a flashlight.
When it's too dark.
I'm like, it's a mechanic, okay?
I was like, I can't see it.
Flashlight...
Flashlight on.
Let me change the graphics.
Um...
Oh, this fried rice is so good, though.
Oh my gosh.
That's like...
Crab in it, too.
It's so good.
Oh, wow.
It gave me, like, extra sauce, but I don't know what it's for.
I don't know what this is for.
I don't know if it's for my beef carpaccio.
I don't think so.
Um...
Josh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will you be playing, uh...
Let me...
Sorry.
Let me eat first, before I read your super chat.
Because I'm hungry.
I'm just so hungry.
Hmm.
Josh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Will you be playing Halo 3?
Um, ODST?
What's ODST?
It takes place between 2 and 3.
And...
In the city introduced into...
It has a really good story.
I'll play all the Halos that are good.
Like, whatever you guys think is a good Halo.
I'll play it.
And I'll just avoid the bad Halo.
One other game I really want to do...
After Halo...
Not after Halo.
Actually, no.
After I complete the Halo series...
Um...
I want to play Gears of War.
Because I never...
Um...
I sort of grew up with Gears of War.
But, like...
It's mostly me watching my dad play Gears of War.
But I know you have to...
Do you have to play Gears of War co-op?
To experience it fully?
Or is it better...
Or is it better solo?
I don't know.
But, like...
Gears of War.
I watched my dad play it growing up.
So, that's something I want to do after...
That's something I want to do...
After...
Uh...
After finishing the Halo series.
Both are gay.
I know my dad would let me play co-op with him sometimes.
But he, like...
But not all the time.
And he preferred solo.
So he doesn't have to wait for me...
To get off school.
He just mostly played solo.
He's like...
Stupid daughter.
Having a good school.
I want to play my Gears of War.
Yeah, I gotta play with him sometimes.
I know I didn't play a lot of the co-op.
I mostly watched him play it.
I'm not too much of a gamer.
Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Besides Halo 2, 3, and Reach...
It should also be worth noting that there's also Halo...
Oh, yeah.
No, no.
Halo DST.
Taking place between...
And still a good bunchy Halo.
But a short game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mad Rad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For real, though.
The Flood is such a badass name.
When I saw people talking about the flood before we got there, I thought they were talking about, like, an actual flood.
Like, you know.
I thought I was like, oh, shit.
Is water just gonna fucking try and drown me or something?
Like, I was like, oh, the rainforest.
Oh, that's where the flood's gonna be.
Because, like, the flood is gonna be, like, you know.
I don't know.
Like, I'm just gonna get flooded by water or some shit.
Or I thought it was a map.
Like, an actual flood?
Or, like...
Or, like, a map or something.
Like, oh, like, oh, yeah.
Wait till she gets the flood.
And I'm like, oh, the chapter name?
The Flood?
Like, it's like, I wonder what happens in the chapter of The Flood.
I wonder what happens.
But no one fucking hit it with fucking zombies.
All right, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
There's also the Halo Wars game.
Oh, is that not the RTS one?
I talked about it.
That was the only Halo game my dad played.
Because he got an Xbox 360, finally, for Gears of War.
And I watched him play the Halo War...
Like, the RTS game of Halo.
I wish RTS wasn't good.
I wish RTS didn't die.
Then I'd stream StarCraft.
That's for the story, though.
I just love the story of StarCraft.
I think StarCraft...
I know, like, people have mixed...
Mixed...
Um...
Have mixed reception with StarCraft, too.
Nope.
But I cried.
When I played it.
At the ending.
When everything was over.
I actually fucking cried.
I thought it was a great ending.
But I also was really young.
I don't know.
Maybe I just didn't know better.
But I was like...
I waited so long.
I was like...
I waited so long for this...
For StarCraft 2 to come out.
That, like...
I was just willing...
I...
Like, anything was good to me.
And...
Don't worry.
I will stream Brood Wars.
Yes, I will.
One day.
Yeah.
I thought...
It was a...
I thought it was a good ending.
But I know a lot of people...
Some people didn't think it was a good ending.
But, like...
I thought it was a great ending.
Janus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Just for clarity...
The order is...
1, 2, 3, ODST, and reach.
Then you can stop.
The later games aren't terrible.
But they're not great.
Then people were like...
Fuck...
Bungie.
Or 343 Studios.
After 4 came out.
Mmm.
Yeah.
Was Cortana, like...
The only improvement?
She was the only improvement...
Out of everything.
It was just her.
Just because they made her, like...
A little sexier.
Oh, Lord.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Fun fact.
Halo was nearly an RTS.
But the developers liked driving the Warthogs.
Too much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hmm...
Gabby, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So...
We see you're a fan of sexy alien ladies.
Like...
Like here again.
Bro, when they say turn her back...
I was like...
Boom!
When they made her...
When they made her human again...
I was like...
Boom!
Thank you for the super chat.
And then she's like...
No, I gotta be a searing...
I gotta be one with the searing.
I was like...
Yeah!
And I was like...
You vanilla fuck!
Not freaky enough for Karen...
Because she deserves someone better...
That can handle her freak.
You vanilla fuck!
Like...
If not...
Not hot...
Um...
I...
Yeah, I was like...
Don't shit on my guy Jim...
Just cause he's vanilla.
Jim, you vanilla shithead!
Embrace the freak!
Bro, okay.
Okay.
Do you guys remember when they...
When Blizz...
Back when Blizzard tried...
When like...
Um...
Was it for BlizzCon?
They released like a video of some...
Of like...
Um...
They like commissioned a...
Studio...
To make a life-size figure...
Of Kerrigan...
And that shit was fucking hot.
I like...
I was like...
Holy fuck!
That's what she could look like?
IRL?
Oh my god!
Damn!
And then...
And then Jim turns her back into a human!
I was like...
You freak!
You...
No, I freak you...
I was like...
Jim, how fucking dare you?
And it wasn't the same.
You know, in Kerrigan...
Um...
It just...
It just wasn't the same.
You know?
Okay.
Uh...
Let me...
Let me show you guys.
Video...
Statue.
Okay.
Let me see.
Uh...
Is this one?
Side...
Oh my god.
Where was the life-size statue of Kerrigan?
Oh, it was so long ago.
It was for BlizzCon, I'm pretty sure.
I saw it...
I saw it in real life.
I saw that statue in real life, by the way.
Because I went to BlizzCon when they showcased it.
Um...
Kerrigan...
Life...
Uh...
Statue.
Life-size statue.
Life-size...
Statue.
Um...
It was a long time ago.
It was like...
A long, long time ago.
Um...
Do they still have the...
Oh my gosh.
Do they have the video of it?
I'm trying to see if they have the video.
Because it was at HQ.
It was at...
They put it in the Blizzard HQ.
Um...
Is this one?
I'm trying to find it, guys.
It was so long ago.
Holy shit.
Open.
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Um...
Here's the money shot.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Go to the...
Go to this.
Scroll down.
Scroll down to the first comment.
And then click on the link that said, Here's the money shot.
I can't show this on stream.
Just...
Go to this.
And then click on the one where it says, Here's the money shot.
And then you'll understand.
And then...
What a shot.
I know.
I was like, Wow.
Wow.
Oh, man.
I wish, like...
Um...
God, they don't...
I think, like...
They don't have the video anymore.
That sucks.
I'm sad.
I can't find, like, an actual good...
Because it was so long ago.
I think it's because, like...
It was so long ago...
That they don't have...
The videos of it is gone.
I'm so sad.
Because I've ever seen a video in the, like...
H...
Like, all...
Most of the stuff that they have right now...
That's on the...
It might be on an archive site or something.
But the only stuff I can find right now...
Are the...
Um...
Are the ones from, like...
Like, old pictures of it at...
At BlizzCon.
He must have took it down or something.
Because I remember seeing the video.
And that video was, like...
Fucking crazy.
Like, of them, like, making it, too.
Um...
But it was...
I remember when I first saw...
That statue at BlizzCon, I was like...
Jesus Christ.
Holy shit.
That shit was crazy.
Yeah.
Uh...
There's one...
Yeah, but that's not the same.
It was a lot...
Um...
It was, like...
There was a lot more to it.
It's not...
Like...
It's, like, very blurry and everything.
I knew there was one.
I knew there was one where it was, like, HD quality.
Um...
Let's see.
Mike, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fun fact.
Taylor2 has a cut enemy.
Like, Juggernaut.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A lot of you think it was super chat.
Olysses.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The little games after Bungie aren't bad, but definitely not as good story-wise.
And that's great gameplay, though.
But not much story.
Yeah, I know Infinite is really good in terms of, like, multiplayer.
Everyone, people have, and then, like, people quit their pro career and other games to try to pursue infinite pro career.
And then, like, and then Bungie fucked up somehow.
I don't know how.
But, like, I guess, like, balancing-wise, they fucked up balancing.
Hmm.
Or something.
And, um...
The pro...
Like, the...
I guess, like, the pro sector has, like, died out.
So, now they just didn't do anything.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're doing the Halo Deep Dive.
May also suggest the Halo Legends Watch-along, the Halo anime anthology movie after Halo 3.
There's an episode made by Toei Animation.
Whoa, maybe you can watch live action, too.
And see John Halo's ass.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll think about it, though.
I'll think about the watch-along.
No!
Don't joke you.
Fuck you.
Don't you bear.
Why?
Why not, guys?
There is no Halo TV show.
Guys, what's wrong with the Halo live action?
Rhyming that Karrigam's invested for a mutator to have bio high heels.
Don't believe me.
Look how fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um... Imposter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Great, of course, Halo made it compatible with crowd control.
Just leaving it out with that information.
Bro, if I put crowd control on it, I'll never beat the game.
I'll prove it to you.
I'll do crowd control Minecraft, and then show you guys how I'll never reach...
I'll never even get to, like, the nether.
Okay, guys.
If I can beat mine... not beat Minecraft...
I'm not gonna beat Minecraft, but like...
If I can, like, get to the...
If I can... Okay, you know what?
If I can get to the...
Ender Dragon...
In crowd... With crowd control on...
In Minecraft...
Um...
Then, I'll do crowd control for a...
First Halo.
Flo.
I'll do it.
I need to test the waters...
before I go straight in.
I...
I need to test the waters before I fucking let you guys get Halo first.
First mod with crowd control.
No.
I'm never being my... exactly.
Exactly, guys.
Okay, this fried rice is so fucking good.
Holy shit.
So about that Minecraft hardcore part too.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't think Min is mentally prepared for that for a long time.
I don't... I don't think she's like...
I don't think she's ready.
Mmm.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna call it here.
So I can finish my meal.
And also, Thad actually needs his walkies now.
I'm a little late on his walkies.
And then, um, so I gotta give him his walkies now.
But thank you all for coming, everybody.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today.
Um, you guys didn't know before I go.
Buy my merch!
My birthday merch is out now!
So, if you guys want to support me, um, and also get something cool along the way, um, I have my merch out.
Let me see if I can grab the graphics real quick.
Whoa!
Where is it?
I always forget where I put the merch graphics.
I forgot to talk about this, too.
Uh, but yes!
It's, it's pinned on my chat right now.
Whoa!
Doki merch!
It's on DokiMerch.com!
There's a lot of merch over here!
That's a lot of merch!
But yes, check out that merch, guys!
Whoa!
Um, it really does help a lot.
And you can get something in return.
And I can do more funky merch, too, in the future.
I can produce more merch in the future.
Um, but yes!
Hey, guys!
Um, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Have you?
Stay up for me.
Head to bed.
He knows he needs to walk, please.
Uh, just stay up for me.
Head to bed, cause you deserve it!
Why?
No.
Oh my gosh.
Alright.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later, everyone!
Bye, guys!
Bye!